BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
WE HAVE A TEN BILLS ON OUR FILE
TODAY.
I AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
IS FILE ITEMS NUMBER TWO AB.
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
NINE AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN
HAPPEN.
PUT OVER.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN EIGHTEEN IS PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT.
SO WITH WITH THAT WE'RE WAITING
FOR AUTHORS TO BEGIN OUR HEARING
TODAY SO IF YOU'RE.
SELLING MEMBERS AG WE ARE CURRY
SANTIAGO -- WHEN MEDINA FRAZIER
CALDERON COOLEY AND HOLDEN?
OUR COMMITTEE AWAITS YOUR
PRESENCE SO WE CAN BEGIN OUR
HEARING TODAY.
HELLO SENATOR WELL WELCOME.
WE WILL HOLD OFF ON SALVATION A
QUORUM FOR A FEW MINUTES HERE
BUT WE HOPE THAT THE AUTHORS
WILL COME FORWARD SO WE CAN HEAR
THEIR BILLS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
WHAT
?
WELL WELCOME WELCOME BACK -- TO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS.
I DO SEE THAT A VERY.
ON TIME AUTHOR IS HERE.
WE WANT TO INVITE UP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AG WE ARE CURRY
TO PRESENT ITEM NUMBER ONE
ASSEMBLY BILL -- TWO TWO EIGHT
WE HAVE FOUR OF OUR MEMBERS
PRESENT BUT WE'RE GONNA WAIT TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO DO THAT
BEFORE YOUR BILL IS.
FINISHED IT'S HEARING.
WITH THAT WE WELCOME YOU TO OUR
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON A GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS.
FIRST EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDED CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS.
AB TWO TWO EIGHT STATES THAT A
FOOD BEVERAGE OR CAUSE MEDIC TO
CONTAIN CVD.
DERIVE FROM INDUSTRIAL HIM IS
NOT ADULTERATED.
THIS PRO HAVE THIS PROHIBITS
RESTRICTION RESTRICTIONS ON
THESE PRODUCTS BASED SOLELY ON
THE FACT THAT THEY CONTAINED CVD
FROM HIM.
ALL OTHER EXISTING FOOD SAFETY
LAWS WOULD APPLY.
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
FEDERAL FARM BILL REMOVED HIM
FROM THE ALL FTA SCHEDULES AND
RE CLASSIFIED HIM AS AN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT.
THIS OPEN DOORS FOR CALIFORNIA
FARMERS TO CULTIVATE HIM AND
IT'S PRESENTED CONSUMERS WITH
THE OPPORTUNITY ACCESS CBD THAT
WILL NOT RESULT RESULT IN A HI.
THIS IS BECAUSE BY DEFINITION
INDUSTRIAL HIM CAN ONLY CONTAINS
THREE TENTHS OF A PERCENT THC OR
LESS WHICH IS A PSYCHOACTIVE
COMPONENT IN MARIJUANA PRODUCTS.
THE MANUFACTURE AND SALE OF HIM
SEE READING CALIFORNIA IS
RAPIDLY EXPANDING BUSINESS WITH
OVER A THOUSAND EMPLOYEES THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY.
WE CAN ALREADY BUY THESE
PRODUCTS TODAY.
A GYM AT LOCAL GYMS COFFEE SHOPS
SHOPS WELLNESS STORES AND EVEN
NOW IT CVS.
SHOULD THE STATE CHOOSE NOT TO
CLARIFY THAT HIM SEE REALLY
PRODUCTS ARE LEGAL THESE JOBS IN
THIS BUSINESS WILL BE LOST AND
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS THE
CONCURRENTLY PURCHASED HIM SEE
BEAUTY PRODUCTS.
WELL FACING NEW BEAR TO
OBTAINING WHAT THEY NEED.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE WITH
UNCERTAINTY AS TO WHETHER HIM
DERIVE CBT MAY BE LAWFULLY SOLD
AND PURCHASING CALIFORNIA.
I. S. FREE I WROTE FOR AB.
TWO TWO EIGHT AND I HAVE SOME
WITNESSES TODAY GREAT THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND WE WELCOME YOUR
WITNESSES WE HAD A LOT TO
WITNESSES FOR MINUTES TOTAL SO
THANK YOU AND YOU CAN BEGIN.
HI THIS IS JIM GROSS -- ON
BEHALF OF THE U. S. TEMP
ROUNDTABLE -- WE REPRESENT
MANUFACTURER'S RETAILERS GROWERS
XTERRA.
HI THIS IS BEEN A NATIONAL
EFFORT AS YOU MAY WELL KNOW I TO
ADDRESS THE LEGALITY --
THROUGHOUT NUMEROUS STATES A
NUMBER OF STATES HAVE ALREADY
ENACTED LEGISLATION
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO THIS.
AND I THINK MOST THE POINTS THAT --
THE AUTHOR MADE ARE ONCE TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION INCLUDING THE
POTENTIAL LOSS OF SALES TAX OF
THIS ISSUE IS NOT A RESULT.
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE GREAT THANK YOU
NEXT NEXT WITNESS.
ANY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE TO WERE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
I'M WE ARE PARTICULARLY
SUPPORTIVE OF HAT CLARIFYING
CHANGES IN THIS BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS AND
RETAILERS TO SELL THESE PRODUCTS
AS THEY HAVE DONE IN THE PAST --
THIS PROVIDES -- ENHANCED
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR AN
INDUSTRY THAT IS STRUGGLING
UNDER THE NEW REGULATORY REGIME --
NUMBER STATES IS JIM NOTED HAVE
ALREADY -- ENACTED MEASURES TO
CLARIFY THAT THESE PRODUCTS --
CAN BE CONSUMED -- OR APPLIED
SAFELY AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION TODAY THANK YOU
PRETTY GOOD THANK YOU -- ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERS RETRO THE
CALIFORNIA HIM COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AND FOR THOSE
THANK YOU SO.
THE OTHERS IN FAVOR OF YOU CAN
JUST INDICATE YOUR SUPPORT AND
YOUR AFFILIATION IF ANY.
NICOLE WATERMAN WITH PRECISION
ADVOCACY GROUP ON BEHALF OF
BLOOM FARMS CAN A CRAFTED NEW
TROPIC REGULATED SOLUTIONS GROUP
AND HER TECH CORP IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS REMARK HERE ON BEHALF
LOCAL EVEN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
RASHARD JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF
EASE TECHNOLOGIES AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DEAR FELLOW IN ON BEHALF ISSUE
TERRA WELLNESS WORD GOD
CALIFORNIA'S WELL AS TEXAS AND
SUPPORTS MEASURE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MICHAEL GREEN CDS CONSULTING
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE GRANGE WHICH IS ONE OF THE
OLDEST EVER CULTURAL
ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA WAS
A SERVICE IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
THREE WE'VE GOT ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN FORTY ONE
COUNTY'S MOST LEGISLATIVE
DISTRICTS.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NICCOLO TO LOOK AT ON BEHALF OF
THE CITIES OF EMERYVILLE IN
OAKLAND SUPPORT KIND OF IMPERIAL
SUPPORT AND THEN CURA AND MARKS
IN SUPPORT.
GREAT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TRACY STEVENS ON
BEHALF OF NOR CAL CANNABIS ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OUR AYE MENTORING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE BUT I
LET'S FIRST ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM BECAUSE I THINK WE DO
HAVE ONCE WITH THE SECRETARY WE
CALL THE ROLL.
GLAZER HERE GLAZER HERE CHIANG.
ARCHULETA PARTULIDAE HERE DOT.
DOT HERE GALGIANI HILL HILL HERE
LEYVA PAN WILK PRESIDENT OKAY WE
HAVE A QUORUM.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN -- ANYTHING YOU
WANT TO ADD TO THIS CONVERSATION
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
YET SENATOR DOT NO CLOTHES THE
BILL OKAY HAD THREATENED THE
APPROPRIATE TIME ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTION
COMMON.
ANYWAY THANK YOU FOR CARRYING
THIS BILL MUCH NEEDED.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS --
INDUSTRIAL HIM CVD DRAWN FROM
INDUSTRIAL HAD ASSEMBLY
NUTRITIONAL PRODUCT.
WE HAD IT IN OUR DIET FOR
HUNDREDS YEARS UNTIL THE
MARIHUANA TAX ACT.
OF NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN AND I
BELIEVE A LOT OF THE ILL HEALTH
GOING ON IT WITH AMERICANS IS
TODAY IS BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THIS UNIT IN THEIR BODIES
BECAUSE DVDS.
SHOWN TO REDUCE INFLAMMATION AND
INFLAMMATION DEMENTIA HEART
ATTACK CANCER GLAUCOMA THIS IS
GOING TO REVOLUTIONIZE
HEALTHCARE IN YOUR ON THE
VANGUARD OF IT IF PEOPLE WANT TO
LEARN MORE LAST WEEK.
FORBES MAGAZINE DID A FABULOUS
ARTICLE ON INTERNATIONAL HAVE
BEEN CALIFORNIA HAPPENED
INTERVIEW YOURS TRULY IN IT.
AND WHY WAS I MIGHT YEAH --
ACTUALLY WE WAS I LIKE FOR MY
MOM -- AND MY DISTRICT IS GONNA
BE THE NAPA VALLEY.
OF CBT.
SO.
MAYBE RIGHT IF I MAY BE AS
POPULAR AS BILL DIED IS ONE DAY.
SO FOR FOR NOT HAVING A COMMENT
THAT SEEM TO BE.
EYES.
SOUNDS LIKE AT THE COMMENTS FROM
SOME OF LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR
TO ME.
A SEND ARCHULETA ANY QUESTIONS
FOR ME YES IS FOR AND I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THE BILL -- WOULD YOU
CLARIFY HOW IT USED IN FOOD
DRAKE IN BECAUSE MEDIC GIVE YOU
THREE EXAMPLES FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND IS.
THAT IT IS SAFE.
YES -- DID.
EACH OF EACH OF THE THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL BE HANDLING
CVD IN THE THROUGHOUT THE
MANUFACTURING PROCESS WELL ALL
RIGHT -- THERE'S NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS I THINK I RECOGNIZE.
I ONE MORE QUESTION YOUR
QUESTIONS TIMER COMMENT NO I GOT
A QUESTION DON'T MAKE COMMENTS
CENTER WILK I WOULD LOVE TO DO
JACKIE THIS BILL ON THE FLOOR
WHEN.
HE GETS THERE.
WE'LL SEE I DON'T THINK WE CAN
HANDLE.
SEE THINKING UP THERE I DON'T
KNOW HIS CENTER DIED YOU STILL
YOU STILL WANT TO MOVE THE MAKE
THE MOTION STILL GIVEN THAT I
THINK IF.
YOU LIKE TO MAKE THE MOST.
NOWTHIS YEAR GETS TO RECKON I
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE CENTER WILK
FOR PURPOSES OF MAKING A MOTION
SIR.
ARE THE BILL'S REMOVED AT SOME
THE WOMAN -- GIVEN THE LOVE THAT
YOU'RE FEELING FROM -- MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
OKAY ARE WITH THAT -- WE HAVE --
YEAH WE HAVE A MOTION DO PASS AS
AMENDED SHE ACCEPTED THE MINUTES
EARLIER TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
AS MADE BY -- STEAM SENATOR
WEALTH SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE KING
ARCHULETA.
ARE TO LET AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA PAN WILK.
HI WELL CAR THAT HAS LOOKS LIKE
JUST BARELY ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT OVER HOLD THE ROLE OF
CONTRASTING MEMBERS.
THANK YOU AND I HOPE YOU HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CO AUTHORS
BECAUSE OF MY COLLEAGUES VERY
ANXIOUS.
OKAY I DO SEE ANOTHER AUTHOR IN
THE HERE TODAY ASSEMBLY WOMAN OR
WHEN LIKE TO INVITE HER TO COME
FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR COMING AND SAGE
THAT COULD BE PAID TO THE
TRUSTEES OF THE CEMETERY IN DOWN
MEANT KERR FUND THAT HAS
RECEIVED APPROVAL FROM THE
CEMETERY AND FUNERAL.
BUREAU TO UTILIZE A UNIT TRUST
DISTRIBUTION METHOD FOR THE FUND.
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDS ARE PROTECTED I AM PLEASED
TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT -- AB
SEVEN NINE FIVE WILL PROVIDE
COMPENSATION LEVELS THAT ARE
REASONABLE AND TEAR DEPENDING ON
THE AMOUNT OF THE FUNDS.
IT WILL ALSO PROVIDE CLEAR
PROTECTIONS FOR THE FUNDING
INCLUDING A REQUIREMENT THAT THE
PRINCIPAL IN INCOME OF THE FUND
IS ONLY AVAILABLE FOR THE CARE
AND MAINTENANCE OF THAT SPECIFIC
CEMETERY PROPERTY.
AND HERE WITH ME TODAY.
IS A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CEMETERY A MORTUARY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIATO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU YOUR WITNESS.
TURN MEMBERS JERRY DOES BEEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CEMETERY MORTUARY
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN IN
ADDRESSING THE COMPENSATION
TEARS AND PROVIDING FOR THE
PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS.
AND OF COURSE SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE SUGGESTED
MANY ANALYSIS TO MAKE IT EVEN
BETTER AND TO PROVIDE THE BUREAU
AN EXTRA YEAR TO DEVELOP THE
REGULATIONS TO MAKE THIS WORK.
THANK VERY GOOD ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WELL -- SOME WOMAN HAPPY TO SAY
THAT YOUR BILL IS NOT DEAD ON
ARRIVAL HERE IN THIS COMEDY.
I DO A SENATOR IS DYING OVER THE
BILL SO.
I ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS.
CASINO DICE US SENATE ARCHULETA.
GOING TO MOVE THE FELL BY
SOMEONE THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DR
AND TESTING.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
AS AMENDED.
A TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
PERFECT GLAZER HI GLAZER AYE
CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA PAN WILK.
OKAY AT A BILL AT IS ALIVE AND
KICKING WITH FIVE VOTES WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THE ROLE OF PERHAPS
THE MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
Q..
ALL RIGHT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
OTHER ASSEMBLY AUTHORS.
YES.
SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
MEDINA FRAZIER CALDERON COOLEY
AND HOLDING IF YOU LIKE YOUR
BILL TO BE HEARD TODAY.
WONDER WHY COURAGE YOU TO BE
HERE NOW WE DO HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR GENTLEMEN AND LADIES --
THERE'S A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
I DO HEAR A MUSHROOM SENATOR
WELCOME THIS IS AB.
TEN EIGHTEEN AS PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT SO.
WITH NO FURTHER COMMENT WILL
CALL THE ROLL ON THAT BILL.
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG
ARCHULETA ACTUALLY I DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA HANDS WILK.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THAT ADVIL -- HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET APPLE HOLDER
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND NOW WE WILL PATIENTLY WAIT
FOR OUR COLLEAGUES ARE GOOD
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY SO.
WE'RE GONNA JUST HOLD THIS
HEARING FOR A FEW MORE MINUTES
SO I HOPE THE OFFICES CAN COME
ON OVER
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
ANOTHER.
AUTHOR HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA LIKE TO WELCOME YOU TO
OUR COMMITTEE HANK YOU.
THIS IS A ITEM NUMBER FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE FOUR NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
YOU CAN BEGIN ANYTIME YOU WANT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE FOUR NINE AB NINE FOUR NINE
WILL PROHIBIT THE INSTALLATION
OF UNSAFE TIRES.
ON CARS WHILE MAINTAINING THE
ABILITY OF RETAILERS TO SELL
THEM FOR OTHER USES.
CONSUMERS PURCHASING USED TIRES
FOR USE ON THE ROAD.
OFTEN NOT AWARE OF THE TRUE
CONDITION.
ESPECIALLY IF THERE'S NO VISIBLE
DAMAGE.
LICENSE AUTOMATED REPAIR DEALERS
ARE MORE EDUCATED THAN CONSUMER.
AND ARE IN A BETTER POSITION TO
JUDGE THE SAFETY OF USED TIRES.
FOR INSTALLATION.
AB NINE FOUR NINE IS IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTION BILL.
IN FACT IT IS SIMILAR TO
VERSIONS THAT HAVE BEEN PASSED
IN COLORADO OHIO AND YOU JERSEY
[inaudible]
AND WE'LL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME TODAY IS A
SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
JEFF SIEVERS REPRESENTING THE
USE US TIRE MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA.
SENATOR MEMBERS COMMITTEE JEFF
SAVERS AND HALF THE U. S. TIRE
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION.
THIS IS THE NATIONAL TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
TWELVE U. S..
HERE'S THAT MANUFACTURE HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
SAFETY IS REALLY THE NUMBER ONE
CONCERN HERE AND SO WHEN WE SORT
OF FOUND OUT THIS YOU KNOW OUR
CODE SECTION HAS BEEN UPDATED
FOR SEVERAL DECADES REFER TO
THIS TIME DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT --
CONSUMER SOMETIMES SEE A LOOK
FOR A MORE AFFORDABLE OPTIONS
WHEN THEY'RE BUYING TIRES TIRES
CAN BE EXPENSIVE AND SOMETIMES
THAT THEY'LL FIND ONES AND
UNBEKNOWNST TO THEM MAY NOT BE
SAFE.
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS OF
THIS BILL SIMPLY IDENTIFY WHAT
IS AN UNSAFE USED TIRE A LOT OF
IT IS BASED ON WHAT IS FOUNDED
THE NATIONAL HIGHWAY
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY ACT.
AND SAY A TIRE DEALER CAN'T
INSTALL AN UNSAFE USED.
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL DOES -- I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION AND THE REST OTHERS
TO SUPPORT SOLELY RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE I GUESS
THAT'S TO BE SEEN HERE IN JUST A
MOMENT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
FAVOR [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH.
HOLD ON JUST ONE SECOND OKAY FIX
THAT MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACK MADONNA FROM
BEHALF OF THE OF CALIFORNIA TIRE
DEALERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA AUTOMOTIVE BUSINESS
COALITION AND THE AUTOMOTIVE
SERVICE COUNCILS OF CALIFORNIA
ALL IN.
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU GREAT THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
MY PLAN AGAIN ON BEHALF OF LES
SCHWAB TIRE CENTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
FAVOR.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CNN WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CENTER
ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU -- OBVIOUSLY IT'S A
MUCH NEEDED BILL MY QUESTION IS
IS IS TAKEN AS TO A DISCLOSURE
BY THE CONSUMER. TO RECEIVE FROM
THAT.
pBE AS A SORT OF AN AS IS OR WHAT
SORT OF DISCLOSURES GOING TO GO
ALONG WITH THIS BECAUSE HOW DO
WE DETERMINE HOW T ANYWAY
DETERMINE WHAT IS SAFE AND WHAT
IS UNSAFE.
AND HOW DO WE PROTECT THE
CONSUMER FROM THE TIRE THAT'S
ONLY GOT FIFTY MILES LEFT.
VERSUS FIVE THOUSAND MILES LEFT
HOW DO WE ADDRESS THAT.
SO THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY
DESIGNED JUST TO PREVENT ED TIRE
DEALER FROM INSTALLING IF THE
CONSUMER HALF AS A BRING IT A
TIRE IN -- FROM INSTALLING IT OR
PREVENTING THEM FROM AT AND
BECAUSE THERE ARE OTHER REASONS
WHY SOMEONE MIGHT BUY A TIRE
THAT MAY BE CONSIDERED UNSAFE.
MAYBE THEY'RE UNAWARE OF IT --
WHEN THEY WHEN THEY PURCHASE IT
AND THEY THINK IT MIGHT BE SAFER
THE CAR BUT THIS IS?
THIS IS BASICALLY APPLIES TO THE
TIRE DEALERS THAT THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO INSTALL AN UNSAFE
TIRE.
THE TIRE DEALERS AND THAT THEY
ARE HERE I CAN ANSWER SOME THIS
QUESTIONS ALSO HAVE THEIR OWN
CODE OF GUIDELINES OF WHAT THEY
NEED TO FOLLOW.
UNDER THE BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR.
OKAY AND ANSWERED MY QUESTION.
IN THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT SIDE WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE ASSEMBLYMEMBER ACTUALLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS THEIR MOTION TO APPROVE
THIS BILL WILL.
SENATOR DODD HAS MOVED -- TO
APPROVE THIS BILL DO PASS AT THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
GLAZER HI THESE ARE AYE TANK.
I ARE TO LET US.
OUR TO LET AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA PAN WILK HI WILL
GUIDE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONGRATULATIONS
THAT BILL IS NOT FOR US TO GET
OUT WILL HOLD REAL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE WE'RE HOLDING FOR JUST
ANOTHER MINUTE OR TWO FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO CALDER
ON COOLEY OR HOLDEN.
THEY ARE.
HEARING THE SOUND OF MY VOICE SO
THAT THEY WILL COME DOWN TO-BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS RIGHT
AWAY THANK YOU
.
ALRIGHT WE'RE BACK IN SESSION
ANOTHER AUTHOR FROM THE ASSEMBLY
GREAT ASSEMBLY IS ARRIVES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO WELCOME.
BILL THIS IS ITEM NUMBER THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL FOR A SEVEN
WELCOME YOU CAN BEGIN AS SOON AS
OU'RE READY.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF WE
WANNA -- EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS AND A I'LL
BE BRIEF OF FOR THE SAKE OF
COMMITTEE A. B. FOUR SEVEN WILL
PROVIDE ALTERNATIVE TO THE
CURRENT STATE.
FLORA SKIPPY AND RADIOGRAPHY A
CERTIFICATION PROCESS WITH A
COUPLE OF WITNESSES -- IF YOU'RE
OKAY WITH A MIXTURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CAM STONE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION I DOCTOR ME HAND
FROM UC DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER IS
GOING TO EXPLAIN WHY CALIFORNIA
NEEDS AN ALTERNATE PROCESS.
FOR DOCTORS PODIATRISTS AND
OTHERS TO BECOME A LICENSE TO
USE FOR US TO BE IN RADIOGRAPHY
AND SURGERY.
THANK YOU CAN FORGET
[inaudible]
WELCOME DOCTOR.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JOHN MAN I'M AN ORTHOPEDIC
SURGEON PROFESSOR IN FULL TIME
ACADEMIC FACULTY AT UC DAVIS
HEALTH.
I'M INVOLVED IN THE TRAINING
ORTHOPEDIC RESIDENTS MEDICAL
STUDENTS POSTGRADUATE TRAINEES.
HAVE YOU EVER BROKEN A BONE IF
YOU'VE HAD YOU'VE HAD TO HAVE
SURGERY TO SET AND STABILIZE THE
BONE THE SURGEON LIKELY USE
FLUOROSCOPY TO MAKE SURE THE
PLACEMENT OF THE BONE AND THEN
YOU NEED TO PLATE SCREWS RIDES
OR ANY APPROPRIATE POSITION.
IT IS AN ACCEPTED TOOL AN
ORTHOPEDIC SURGERY WHERE BY LIVE
ACTUARIES ARE SEEN IN REAL TIME.
AND SHOT BY MOLD A MO BY MACHINE
WITH THE ANGLE OF YOU CAN BE
CHANGED.
DRAMATIC FRACTURES AND THE YOUNG
PATIENT AS WELL AS IN THE
ELDERLY ARE FREQUENTLY REQUIRE
THE USE OF FLORA SKIPPY.
I'VE HANDED OUT X. RAYS THAT
SHOW WHAT YOU CAN SEE WHILE
USING FLUOROSCOPY.
USE THE FLOOR OSCAR BEES
PARTICULAR IMPORTANTE OPERATING
ONE MORE TIME IS CRITICAL IN THE
PATIENT IS RELATIVELY IMMOBILE.
WE NEED TO KNOW THAT THE BONDS
ARE WELL ALIGNED IN THREE
DIMENSIONS AND THEN THAT THE
MULTIPLE PIECES OF HARDWARE ARE
PROBABLY PLACED WITHOUT
COMPROMISING THE ALIGNMENT OF
THE FRACTURE.
THIS ISN'T DONE WHILE THE BONES
CAN FAIL TO HEAL OR HE'LL IN THE
WRONG ALIGNMENT AND REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL SURGERY AND IS.
MORBIDITY TO THE PATIENT.
THE PROBLEM THAT A BEFORE SEVEN
ADDRESSES WHEN ORTHOPEDIC
SURGEONS MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
FROM OTHER STATES ARE COMPLETE
THEIR TRAINING THEY KNOW TO
APPLY FOR THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
LICENSE.
BUT THE REQUIREMENTS FOR A FLORA
SKIPPY CERTIFICATE OFTEN TAKE
THEM BY SURPRISE SINCE IT IS NOT
REQUIRED IN MOST OTHER STATES.
WHEN THEY APPLY FOR MEDICAL
STAFF PRIVILEGES THE HOSPITAL
ASKED FOR THE FLOOR OSCAR B.
CERTIFICATE?
THEY REALIZE IT IS REQUIRED IN
CALIFORNIA THEY START THE
APPLICATION PROCESS PROCESS
WHICH CAN OFTEN TAKE SIX MONTHS.
NOT HAVING THE FLORA SKIPPY
CERTIFICATE PREVENTS THE SURGEON
FROM TAKING EMERGENCY ROOM CALL
AND USING THE FOR US COULD BE IN
SURGERY.
THIS CAN BE DETRIMENTAL TO
PATIENT CARE.
PLUS TO BE IT IS POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS THAT IS WHY DOCTORS
SUCH AS ORTHOPEDIC SURGEONS WHO
USED FOR US TO BE IN THE
PRACTICE RECEIVE EXTENSIVE
TRAINING ON ITS USE IN MEDICAL
SCHOOL AND RESIDENCY.
WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR PATIENTS
AND WE ALSO WANT TO PROTECT
OURSELVES AND OUR COWORKERS AS
WE ARE ALSO EXPOSED TO THE SAME
RADIATION DURING THE SURGERY.
THAT'S WHY EVERYONE WORKING IN
THE OPERATING ROOM THAT IS USING
FOR US BE WEARS AN XRAY BADGE
THAT TRACKS AND INDIVIDUALS X.
RAY EXPOSURE OVER TIME.
AND SPECIAL TECHNIQUE TECHNIQUES
ARE USED TO MINIMIZE RADIATION
EXPOSURE TO ALL PARTIES.
WE ARE NOW ALSO ACQUIRED TO HAVE
ANNUAL TRAINING AND FOR US TO BE
RADIATION SAFETY.
BY OUR INDIVIDUAL HOSPITALS IN A
S. SIS OR AMATORY SURGERY CARE
CENTERS.
I WOULD URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TO CREATE ANOTHER AVENUE
FOR TO PEAK SURGEONS TO
DEMONSTRATE REINFORCE THEIR
KNOWLEDGE AND RADIATION THERAPY.
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
FAVOR YES DIANNE SHIP YOU TO SKI
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION.
JUST WANT TO REINFORCE WHAT
DOCTOR ME HAND SAID AND IS COOL
PHOTOS THAT HE HE HANDED OUT --
WHEN A AND PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT FOR PEDIATRIC PATIENTS
WHEN THEY ARRIVE IN THE OPERATE
IN THE -- OUR EMERGENCY ROOM --
DOCTORS CAN'T TELL IF IT'S A
CLOSE FRACTURE AND DOCTOR ME AND
CORRECT ME IF I GET TOO FAR OFF
HERE THEY CAN'T TELL WHETHER
THEY NEED TO OPEN IT UP AND
ACTUALLY REALIGNED THE BONES AND
PLATE AND PUT THE SCREWS INTO
PUT IT BACK TOGETHER.
FLUOROSCOPY IS A GOOD TOOL FOR
THE SURGEONS TO EVALUATE THE
FRACTURE BEFORE THEY OPEN UP THE
PATIENT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IN
THE O. R. AND PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT FOR PEDIATRIC CARE --
ALSO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT --
TO AMPLIFIED THAT SURGEONS ARE
EXPOSED TO RADIATION EVERYDAY IN-THE OPERATING ROOM THEY OF ALL
PEOPLE.
WANT TO BE SAFE FROM RADIATION
EXPOSURE AS WELL SO THEY ARE
WELL AWARE OF THE DANGERS OF
RADIATION -- AND WANT TO PROTECT
OUR PATIENTS AS WEALTH AND SELF
SO WE URGE AN AYE VOTE GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
RIGHT SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PODIATRIC MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE CO SPONSORS
ON THIS MEASURE AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT I THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS TO MAD RIVERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY IN SUPPORT.
GREAT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THIRTY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COULD MAKE A WAY AT THE TABLE
FOR A COUPLE FOLKS TO SIT DOWN
THAT BE GREAT.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE IF YOU
CAN IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND YOU
CAN BEGIN YES MISTER TURN
MEMBERS BOB ACTING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RHEOLOGICAL
SOCIETY.
RADIOLOGIST I WAS HERE BOARD
CERTIFIED IN THE SPECIALTY --
IMAGING AND RADIATION SAFETY ARE
PROMINENT IN THEIR PRACTICE.
OUR OPPOSITION IS NOT BASED UPON
THE TECHNOLOGY IS WONDERFUL IT'S
USABLE BY ORTHOPEDIC SURGEONS
AND BY OTHERS ARE OF CONCERN IS
WITH THE ADOPTION OF NEW
STANDARDS THAT ARE UNCLEAR IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY ACTUALLY
REQUIRE.
THE PERMIT AND THE TEST WAS WAS
ESTABLISHED BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE RELIGION
HEALTH BRANCH OF THE SURVEY OF
THE TRAINING FOR NON RADIOLOGIST
PHYSICIANS AND FOR US COULD BE
AND FOUND AND CONSISTENCY.
THAT IT WAS BETTER TO HAVE A
STATEWIDE PROCESS.
AND IT HAS THE COULD BE
ADMINISTERED TO ALL USERS OF AND
THAT WAS ADOPTED BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE SINCE THEN FOR
OTHER STATES HAVE ADOPTED
SIMILAR REQUIREMENTS.
THE PASSAGE RATE ON THE TEST IS
83% FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS THE
TEST IS NOT AN IMPEDIMENT -- TO
USE OF AND WE DO NOT WANT TO BE
AN IMPEDIMENT TOUSE.
SO WE WOULD PROPOSE THAT YOU FIX
THE PROBLEM.
OF IN TERMS OF WHAT'S BEING
ALLEGED BY THE PROPONENTS AND
THAT'S THE THE DELAYS IN GETTING.
THE APPLICATION AND PERMIT
ESTABLISHED.
SO WE SUGGESTED TO OF THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS THAT.
THIS BILL SIMPLY SAY THAT WHEN A
NEW POSITION COMES TO CALIFORNIA
IS ALREADY DOING FLUOROSCOPY
THAT THEY BE ALLOWED TO GET THE
PERMIT IMMEDIATELY AND THE WITH
A CERTAIN PART OF A PERIOD OF
TIME SAY ONE YEAR THEY COULD
TAKE THE TEST.
THE TEST IS ON RADIATION SAFETY
AND PROTECTION ESSENTIAL FOR ALL
INVOLVED.
THE PATIENT THE POSITION AND THE
TECHNOLOGIST IN THE ROOM AND WE
THINK THAT STANDARD IS
REASONABLE -- SO THAT'S THE
BASIS OF OUR OPPOSITION
pRECOMMENDATION I WILL SAY ON THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS THAT UNDER
EXISTING LAW.
A RESIDENTS AND FELLOWS IN
TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE EXEMPT
FROM LICENSURE SO THERE'S NO
NEED FOR THAT TO CREATE A
PATHWAY FOR THEM IN THIS PROCESS.
FORGET OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR
DOORS AVERAGE ME I REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGISTS I'M AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE.
AND A RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGISTS
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT
PROTECTING THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA AND INSURING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF ALL
PATIENTS AND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS.
DURING FLUOROSCOPIC PROCEDURES.
THE CURRENT PERMIT PROCESS
INCLUDES PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS
TO PROVE THEIR KNOWLEDGE VIA AN
EXAMINATION. TO ENSURE THEIR
PROPERLY EDUCATED REGARDING
RADIATION PROTECTION UNDERSTAND
EFFECTIVE RADIATION ON HUMAN
TISSUES.
AND TO KNOW HOW TO DECREASE THE
DOSE TO THE PATIENT.
IN FOR OSCAR P. UNLIKE OTHER
IMAGING MODALITIES THERE'S NO
CONTROL OVER REDUCING RADIATION
DOSE OTHER THAN WHAT THE
OPERATOR DOES. FOR EXAMPLE THE
EXPOSURE SETTINGS THE DURATION
OF EXPOSURE ALL OF THOSE ARE
PARAMETERS THAT THE OPERATOR
CONTROLS.
WITH THE RECENT REMOVAL OF THE
JOINT COMMISSION'S ANNUAL
RADIATION SAFETY TRAINING.
IF THIS BILL PASSES
COMPREHENSIVE EDUCATION TO
PROTECT PATIENTS WILL BE
ELIMINATED.
THEREFORE THE QUESTION IS WHAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED OF THE
PHYSICIANS TO ENSURE PROPER
EDUCATION AND UNDERSTANDING OF
RADIATION PROTECTION TECHNIQUES
HOW CAN WE ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
OUR PATIENTS AND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS DURING RADIOGRAPHY
AND FLUOROSCOPY PROCEDURES?
ARE STRONG FLOOR LICENSURE LAWS
HAVE PROTECTED THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE HELP
US PROTECT OUR PATIENTS
PHYSICIANS TECHNOLOGISTS
EVERYONE FROM EXCESSIVE
RADIATION DOSE.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON A
BEFORE SEVEN AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PRICING THAT WILL BRING THE
ISSUE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ID OR YOUR
WITNESSES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND TO THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED HERE TODAY.
SURE ABSOLUTELY I'LL BE BRIEF --
IF YOU WANT TO WEBER YOU YOU MAY
BE A CORD THAT IF THE CHAIR
ALLOWS US TO LOOK SIMPLY WERE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT OF A
QUICKER -- FASTER AND MORE
EFFICIENT PROCESS RATHER THAN
GOING THROUGH -- THROUGH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND WAITING FOR
MONTHS THAT THEY COULD DO IT AT
A LOCAL HOSPITAL.
I MEAN THESE ARE DOCTORS
PHYSICIANS ARE.
VERY WELL EDUCATED IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD I CAN TAKE A TEST
AT A LOCAL FACILITY. FOR A
CERTIFICATION PROCESS TO THE
LOCAL FACILITY THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO TEMPER I
TRY TO CHANGE -- STANDARDS --
AND IF I DO YOU WE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION BEFORE I'M OPEN TO
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT STANDARD
IF THAT'S A CONCERN BUT WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS LET'S MAKE IT
MORE EFFICIENT LET'S HAVE AND
HAVE THEM TAKE IT -- AT THE
LOCAL FACILITIES.
AND THAT WOULD NOT BE A
REQUIREMENT A STATE LAW THAT
WOULD BE A REQUIREMENT THAT THE
FACILITIES PROVIDE FOR THE USE
OF THEIR THEIR FACILITY THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING.
TO YES ALL RIGHT.
YOU WANNA ELABORATE ON THAT ANY
FURTHER YEAH I'M I'M A LITTLE
CONFUSED BECAUSE I THOUGHT I
THIS YEAR FOR THE FIRST TIME VIA
MY HOSPITAL.
TOOK A FLORA ASK ANNUAL TRAINING
FOR OSCAR BE EXAM AS PART OF MY
YEARLY TRAINING.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING WAS THE
JOINT COMMISSION WAS REQUIRING
THAT.
IN SO ALL OF US ALL MEMBERS OF
UC DAVIS HEALTH -- IN THEIR
ANNUAL TRAINING THIS YEAR WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST YEARS WE HAD
THE ANNUAL FLUOROSCOPY TRAINING
EXAM.
THAT WE WERE REQUIRED TO TAKE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT UP QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CENTER CENTER GALGIANI I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I THINK ADDITIONAL
TRAINING IS ALWAYS A GOOD THING
BUT IN THIS CASE IT'S BEEN
POINTED OUT THAT.
THAT IT TAKES UP TO SIX MONTHS
TO HAVE A A TEST APPROVED BYOUR
OUR GOVERNMENT PROCESS AND I
THINK THAT THAT ONLY HOLD THINGS
UP.
AND ENDED A DAY AND TIME WHERE
WE HAVE -- AT THE TROUBLE OF
ACCESS TO CARE AND AND PATIENTS
BEING ABLE TO ACTUALLY GET THEIR
PLANETS GET THEIR TREATMENTS.
WE NEED TO DO MORE TO INCREASE
AT ACCESS I'M THANKING YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JUDGE CLOSE.
I THINK MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIVEAU GET SENATOR HILL IS MOVE
THE BILL.
WITH THAT OF THE SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS -- JUST BE
CLEAR HERE.
THIS IS -- AS AMENDED.
AS AMENDED DO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
HI GLAZER AYE TANK.
CHIANG AYE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
PAN WILK YEAH.
WILK NOW -- SO WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THE ROLE OF CONTRAPTION MEMBERS
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PRESENTING.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- COOLEY
IS HERE.
LIKE TO A WELCOME HIM TO THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL. TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT SEVEN ARE YOU CAN
BEGIN -- AS WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY VERY GOOD.
COLLEAGUES I THANK YOU FOR THE
PRAYERS REPRESENTING PRESENTING
AB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT TO YOU.
BEFORE I DASH OFF TO MY RULES
COMMITTEE.
OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
RELATES TO PRESERVING.
THIS MY VIEW OF IT.
PRESERVING ACCOUNTABLE SYSTEMS.
FOR CANNABIS DELIVERY IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES HE
EFFECTIVE VIA EFFECTIVE TRACK
AND TRACE PROCESS.
PART OF FOOD NOW CULTURE IS
REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH A TRACK
AND TRACE PROGRAM.
A FOR A PARTY MOVEMENT
CANVASSING CANVAS PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRIBUTION
CHAIN.
SO THIS BILL IS ALL ABOUT
ENSURING ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PROTECTED AGAINST ILLICIT MARKET
ACTIVITY.
SUPPORTS QUALITY OF LIFE IN
EVERGREEN CALIFORNIA.
AT A MINIMUM INTEREST
INFORMATION COLLUDED MUST
CONTAIN THE LICENSEE RECEIVING A
PRODUCT THE TRANSACTION DATE.
THE COLD RIVER WAS A PRODUCT
REGION [inaudible]
EIGHT THIS BILL.
ADDITIONAL REQUIRES THAT THE
TRACK INCREASES MACU THE SALE
POINT.
AND WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS.
A ONE AT RETAIL PROMISES REFUSAL
EVERY.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE TRACK
INCREASES TO BE INTEGRATED WITH
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEMS SO
CALLED CLIENTS.
BY JULY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY SO
ABOUT A YEAR FROM NOW.
RECENT MEMBERS ALSO REQUIRE THE
DELIVERY INVENTORY LEDGER.
WHICH PROVIDES A RECORD OF
WHAT'S ON THE VEHICLE.
OF WHICH ALL DELIVERY DRIVERS
ARE REQUIRED TO KERRY ALSO BE
UPLOADED TO TRACK AND TRACE.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT SHOULD
ALLOW FOR POLITICAL EVERY DRIVER
OVER.
THEY CAN COMPARE THE APPLE
VERSION OF WHAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE IN A VEHICLE WITH WHAT IS
PRESENT.
THIS WILL PROTECT LAW FOR
DELIVERY FROM UNDUE DELAY ALSO
SUPPORT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
JUST KIND OF MAKES A LITTLE
CONNECTION.
SO THAT THEY KNOW THAT THE
VEHICLE IS STOPPED HAS WHAT IT
SHOULD HAVE [inaudible]
ON SO REQUIRED TO DELIVER
INFORMATION TO WILL HELP ENSURE
PRODUCT SAFETY.
LET LONG FORCE A REAL TIME
INFORMATION ON LEGITIMATE
DELIVERIES.
ARE BEING MADE ALLOW THEM TO
FOCUS ATTENTION ON ILLICIT
ACTIVITIES OR OTHER OBLIGATIONS
A HALF BECAUSE OF COURSE.
ANYTIME IN OFFICERS OUT THEY CAN
ENCOUNTER SOME -- WITHOUT ACCESS
TO THIS INFORMATION LAW
ENFORCEMENT MAY ACTUALLY
DETAINED LEGAL OPERATORS BY
MISTAKE.
WAS JUST DESIGNED TO TIGHTEN UP
THE SYSTEM.
AND WHILE I'M SURE RESUMES OF
CAUSE SOME CONCERN.
I'D BE HAPPY TO OF RYSTALS
CONCERTS BUT I DO FEEL THIS
LEDGER COMPONENT.
IS ABOUT MAKING THE SYSTEM
ACCOUNTABLE WHICH I THINK
SUPPORTS THE INTEREST OF THOSE
IN THE INDUSTRY FRANKLY ALL OF
UR CONSTITUENTS THERE'S A
BROADER RANGE OF VIEWS ON THE
GENERAL TOPIC AROUND THE STATE --
AND I THINK.
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT'S GOING AND LAW FORCE COULD
CHECK ON IT JUST.
CARRIES GOOD.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
GREAT THANK YOU SOMEONE NUMBER
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IS COME FORWARD.
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MY NAME IS JEREMY SIEGEL ON HIM
OUT OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES --
EASE IS A GREAT SUPPORTER OF THE
ATTENDED THIS BILL -- HE'S
ITSELF ON SUPPORTERS OF POSSIBLY
TWENTY RETAILERS IN THE STATE
THAT CONDUCT LIVERIES HOWEVER
THE THE FINAL AMENDMENTS --
BECAUSE THE LOGISTICAL ISSUES
FOR NOT ONLY EITHER FOR ALL ITS
PARTNERS THE OTHER THE CONCEPT
OF A DELIVERY MANIFEST -- LEDGER
DOES NOT EXIST IN OTHER STATES
THAT CURRENTLY SUPPORT METRIC
AND HAVE DELIVERY BUILT INTO IT.
AND THE METRIC ITSELF IS A THIS
IS ON THE TRACKS FROM A POINT TO
POINT -- TRANSACTION AND
DELIVERY AND FOR INSTANCE IN
OREGON EACH TIME OR A DELIVERY
IS IS A PLACE IN ORDER THAT IS
ABOUT IT IN THE METRIC INCLUDES
THE INFORMATION SUCH AS THE THE
PRODUCT THAT ARE BEING SOLD IN
THE THE FINAL DESTINATION.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE HAVE
A CONCEPT WHERE.
RETAILERS ARE ALLOWED TO PLACE
PRODUCT IN THEIR VEHICLES.
THAT IS MY IT PURCHASED THIS IS
THE THE INVENTORY THAT IS
COLLECTING THE LEDGER.
IS NOT YET -- ASSIGNED TO A
FINALIST NATIONS OF METRIC
ITSELF DOES NOT CURRENTLY HAVE
THE CAPACITY.
TO RECORD THAT NAM SO HE'S
LOOKING FOR TO WORKING WITH.
ON THIS ON AT A PERSON COOLEY TO
DISCUSSES AND FIND A SOLUTION AT
THAT DOES SUPPORT THE INDUSTRY
AND ALLOW FOR THIS -- CONTINUED
TRACKING TRACING OF THE THE
CONTENT THAT THE COMPLETE --
PROCESS FROM SEA TO SAIL.
AGAIN OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF CLEVELAND BLACKBIRD LOGISTICS --
TO CANADA'S BUSINESSES OPERATING
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
COOLEY OF AS ONE OF THE LARGEST
OPERATORS AND I'M BASED OUT OF
SAN JOSE.
WE ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT WHAT THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT IS -- THE
ILLICIT MARKET IS ONE THAT WE'RE
VERY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO KEEP
THE ILLICIT TO TO KEEP THE
ILLICIT MARKET FROM GROWING --
AND PREFERABLY TO MAKE IT SHRINK --
WOULD BE DESIRABLE UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IN ITS
CURRENT FORM WITH THE USE OF THE
OF THE LEDGER IS IS CREATE AN
ADDITIONAL.
OUR WORKLOAD BURDEN ON THE
COMPANY'S WITHOUT PROVIDING ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO THE
STATE OR TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHEN WE TAKE A ORDER -- AT
KHALIFA DOT COM -- FOR PRODUCT
FOR DELIVERY WE UPLOAD A GREAT
DEAL OF INFORMATION TO TRACK AND
TRACE ON THAT INCLUDES ON WHO
THE CUSTOMER IS WHAT THE PRODUCT
IS INTERESTS ARE.
THAT DOT THE LEDGER IS SOMETHING
THAT IS CARRIED BY THE DRIVER
THAT DEFINES WHAT IS IN THE
VEHICLE AT THE TIME THE DRIVER
IS OUT ON THE ROAD.
IT IS EXACTLY THE SAME
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE JUST
UPLOADED TO TRACK AND TRACE ON
WHEN WE MADE THE SALE -- AT AT
THE POINT WHEN THE CUSTOMER
ORDERED IT. TO WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DOING IS CREATING
A DUPLICATIVE -- SYSTEM OF OF
PUTTING THE SAME INFORMATION
INTO THE SAME TRACK AND TRACE
SYSTEM WHICH SHOULD SIMPLY ADDS
TO OUR BURDEN.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT KHALIFA IN
PARTICULAR BUT MANY OF THE
DELIVERY COMPANIES ARE DOING
THOUSANDS OF DELIVERIES A MONTH.
THAT'S NOT AN INCONSEQUENTIAL
AMOUNT OF WORK THAT WE HAVE TO
ENGAGE IN IN ORDER TO PUT THE
SAME INFORMATION IN A SECOND
TIME THAT WAS JUST PUT IN.
MAYBE AN HOUR BEFORE.
WE WANT IT ALSO DOES NOT PROVIDE
ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT LAW ENFORCEMENT --
UNDER OTHER PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL CAN ACCESS THAT ON THAT
TRACK AND TRACE MATERIAL -- AND
THEY CAN KNOW THAT WHAT THE
DRIVER HOUSE IN THE VEHICLE IS
PRODUCT THAT WAS PURCHASED BY
THE BY THE CUSTOMER -- WHEN WHEN
THAT WAS ORDERED -- IF THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS THAT WE CAN CAN USE
FILL THE LEDGER OR THE OR THE
POINT OF SALE OF SALE TRACK AND
TRACE. TO TO TO GET RID OF THE
ILLICIT MARKET WE'RE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO CONTINUE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THIS AGAIN WE SHARE
HIS INTENT.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO FINDING A
SOLUTION THAT DOES NOT CREATE AN
UNDUE BURDEN ON US.
GOOD ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY STEVENS
REPRESENTING NOR CAL CANNABIS WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A SUPPORT ON FILE
PRIOR TO THESE AMENDMENTS WE TOO
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR.
WE AGREE WITH THE INTENT WE'RE
JUST A LITTLE BIT CAN LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DETAILS AS
WELL AND WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
FORWARD WORKING WITH HIM TO
CLARIFY THIS THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD ANY OTHER WITNESSES
YES YES AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE TO HAVE A SUPPORT
POSITION ON THE BILL.
BUT DUE TO CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY
OUR MEMBERS SEASON CLEAVER AND
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR TO TRY TO RESOLVE
THOSE CONCERNS THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
FAVOR AGAINST WINNERS ALL RIGHT
WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SYSTEM IN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED I'M SURE THAT'S A
LIKE THE QUESTION FOR MY
COLLEAGUES.
WELL I THINK OF I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THE INDUSTRIES HERE AND
THAT THEY DID NOT COORDINATED
ANNE'S SAYS THEY HAVE.
OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF COMPLIANCE
ISSUES AND I'M HEARING FROM
COOLEY BUT THEY'RE SORT OF WANT
TO SAY WE ALREADY DO IT THE
OTHER ONE SAYS WE CAN'T DO IT
BECAUSE IT'S COMPLICATED THINGS.
ARE.
I'LL JUST HAVE A STANDPOINT OF
ON A I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT.
PROVIDE AN ELECTRONIC RECORD
THAT ALONG FOR SOME SHE CAN PULL
DOWN.
THE DOCUMENTS WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO FIND THE VEHICLE.
I THINK THAT SUPPORTS A TYPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY IS IT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE PUBLIC WOULD
SUPPORT.
I THINK IT MAKES FOR EASIER
ENCOUNTERS BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND DELIVERY DRIVER
[inaudible]
ON I AM CERTAINLY WILLING TO
TALK WITH FOLKS BUT I ACTUALLY.
OF WHEN I LOOK AT THE STATUTE.
THERE IS NOT THE PARTICULARITY
AS TO WHAT'S ACTUALLY IN THE
VEHICLE -- THERE'S BEEN ADDED BY
THIS LEDGER -- I AM I WILL SAY
I'M NOT WEDDED TO A PARTICULAR
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTION AS TO HOW
THE WHAT LEDGER GETS -- CONVEYED
MADE AVAILABLE.
AND I'M CERTAINLY NOT TRYING TO
FAVOR ONE MODALITY OVER ANOTHER.
BUT I DO THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A
SYSTEM OF ACCOUNTABILITY WITH
THIS TRANSFER AROUND THE STATE.
VERY GOOD THAT I AND I GUESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- ONE SOLUTION
WOULD BE JUST TO CURTAIL
DELIVERIES RIGHT IT IS WITH AND
THE DELIVERIES YOU WOULDN'T HAVE
ANY TECHNICAL ISSUES AFTER.
THERE'S PROBABLY PROPONENTS FOR
THAT VIEW SURE THAT THERE ARE
SOME PRETTY SERIOUS PRODUCT TO
HAVE OUT.
HI IN VEHICLES AROUND OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD IT'S NOT SO
DIFFERENT THAN ALCOHOL OR OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE SENSITIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY SO I AM SURPRISED TO
HEAR.
THE CONCERNED ABOUT -- SOMEHOW
THE TECHNOLOGY IS NOT NOT THERE
FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
AND I'M SURPRISED ME YEAH.
IF I MAY I THINK WORKERS I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND
CLOSE THE LOOP MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE TO ME.
THANK ON I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND TRYING TO DO THAT
AND SO I AM A LITTLE SURPRISED
AND BUT I ASSUME YOU'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THAT.
THE OPPONENTS WHO ARE HERE TODAY
TO TRY TO SEE IF YOU CAN WORK
THROUGH THEIR ISSUES IS THE BILL
WAS FORWARD.
INDEED I WILL AND I WANT TO SAY
YOU KNOW FROM THE EARLIEST TIMES
WE SAT IN THIS HEARING ROOM AND
DISCUSSED OUR BILL WITH YOUR
PREDECESSORS THE MEDICAL BILLS.
I HAVE A HUGE CONCERN ON THE
ACCESS OF MEDICAL MARIJUANA TO
FOLKS WHO NEED.
I THINK THAT IN IN THE BIG RUSH
TO RECREATIONAL.
I SORT OF FEEL WE STEP BACKWARDS
A LITTLE BIT IN LETTING FOLKS
FOR WHOM.
THERE'S A MEDIC MEDICALLY
INDICATED USE AND I THINK THE
AFFORDABLE AND EASE OF ACCESS TO
THAT POPULATION IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
AND SO THIS SORT OF I I DON'T
FAVOR ROLLING AWAY DELIVERY I
THINK IT ACTUALLY PLAYS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE.
BUT I WOULD REMEMBER THOSE FOLKS
ARE MOST FOR HOMELESS THERE'S A
VULNERABILITY A HELPFUL REALLY
THE WORK IN A VERY GOOD OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES.
YOU'RE THE COMMITTEE THAT LIKE
TO GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
CLOSE.
QUESTION I VOTE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK IN THIS AREA I THINK YOUR
BILL MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO ME
AND I KNOW THERE'S SOME CONCERNS
AND ISSUES.
I HOPE THEY CAN BE WORKED OUT
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS A IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE -- THIS IS A A
VERY PRUDENT AND MODEST STEP
FORWARD AYE AYE IT DOESN'T HAVE
A PHASE IN.
THEIR SUNSET DATE ON THIS RACE
USE ME YESTERDAY I THINK THE
START DATE IS A YEAR FROM --
THIS JULY.
SAID IS THAT RIGHT.
YEAH JULY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ASSEMBLY
PROVIDE -- A LOT OF TIME -- TO
TRY TO GET THE TECHNOLOGY AND
THE RIGHT SHAPE.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT THE MEMBERS
ARE MOTION.
CENTER GALGIANI IS MOVE THE BILL
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
GLAZER AYE.
GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA PARTULA AYE
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
I LEYVA HAND WILK [inaudible]
WILL GUIDE.
ALL RIGHT THAT DEATH HAD BILL
CURRENTLY ENJOYS ENOUGH SUPPORT
TO GET APPLE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OF AND PERHAPS IN MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT NEXT UP THE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CALDER ON IT PETRIE-NORRIS.
SEE THAT YOU ARE HERE WELCOME TO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS.
AND YOU CAN BEGIN A TIME YOU
READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO SHARE
PRESENTATION OF THIS BILL WITH
MY JOIN AUTHOR ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CRIED PETRIE-NORRIS.
A BEFORE WE BEGIN WE BEGIN I'D
LIKE TO USE OUR BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- THAT ARE
LISTED -- INCOMING FIVE THE
ANALYSIS I'D ALSO LIKE TO COMMIT
TO BROADENING THE LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE ALL PRACTITIONERS WHO
PERFORM PELVIC EXAMS INCLUDING
NURSE PRACTITIONERS NURSE
MIDWIVES.
ARE REQUIRED TO GIVE THIS
PAMPHLET OUT AND FINALLY I
COMMIT TO ENSURING THE PAMPHLET
IS CREATED IN BOTH SPANISH AND
ENGLISH BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
INTO RESEARCH THE POSSIBILITY
PROVIDING THIS PAMPHLET AND
OTHER LANGUAGES.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR ITS DILIGENT RESEARCH AND
ALSO FOR ITS SUGGESTIONS.
THIS BILL WILL EMPOWER PATIENTS
BY GIVING THEM MUCH NEEDED
INFORMATION GIVEN THE MORE
INVASIVE NATURE.
OF PELVIC PELVIC EXAMINATIONS IN
RECENT HORRIFIC TALES OF ABUSE
DURING THESE EXAMS IT HAS BECOME
APPARENT THAT PATIENTS WOULD
BENEFIT FROM ADVANCE INFORMATION.
ABOUT WHAT TO EXPECT DURING A
PELVIC EXAM.
AB TEN THIRTY REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD IN
COORDINATION WITH RELEVANT TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS TO DEVELOP AN
INFORMATIONAL PAMPHLETS FOR
PATIENTS UNDERGOING.
GYNECOLOGICAL PELVIC EXAMINATION.
THIS PAMPHLET WOULD INCLUDE
BASIC INFORMATION REGARDING HOW
THE PROCEDURE SHOULD BE PER
PROPERLY PERFORMED.
PRIVACY AND SANITARY SANITARY
EXPECTATIONS AND BOARD CONTACT
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO REPORT
ANY INSTANCES OF MISCONDUCT.
AB TEN THIRTY REQUIRES THAT THIS
INFORMATIONAL DOCUMENT BE
PROVIDED TO PATIENTS PRIOR TO
THEIR FIRST PUBLIC EXAM.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
FEMALE PATIENTS RECEIVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED IN ORDER
TO IDENTIFY AND HOPEFULLY
PREVENT INSTANCES OF SEVERE
MISCONDUCT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
IN WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
IS CHRISTY LEACH A CONSTITUENT
OF MINE WHO IS ALSO.
THE SOURCE OF WHERE THIS BILL
CAME FROM.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU I AM I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
BUSINESS A SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF TEN THIRTY
MY NAME IS CHRISTY LEACH AND I
AM ONE OF MORE THAN.
SEVEN HUNDRED SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ASAULT THAT OCCURRED IN
THE U. S. C. HEALTH CENTER AT
THE HANDS OF DR GEORGE TEN ALL --
I AM ONE OF OF BETWEEN AN
ESTIMATED 1-000-021-4000
STUDENTS THAT HE SAW DURING HIS
TWENTY SEVEN YEAR TENURE AT U.
S. C..
MY STORY IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT --
THAN MOST OF THE SURVIVORS AS I
DID NOT -- GO TO THE STUDENT
HEALTH CENTER THAT DAY FOR A
GYNECOLOGICAL VISIT I ACTUALLY
WENT BECAUSE I HAD A COLD
SYMPTOMS THAT WERE LASTING WAY
WELL OVER SEVERAL WEEKS AND I
FELT THAT YOU KNOW I MIGHT NEED
ANTIBIOTICS -- SO HE DIAGNOSED
ME WITH THE SIZE SINUS INFECTION
GIVE ME ANTIBIOTICS AND THEN HE
PROCEEDED TO TELL ME THAT HE WAS
NOT JUST A GENERAL DOCTOR BUT
THAT HE WAS AN OBGYN -- AND
CONVINCE ME THAT I SHOULD HAVE
MY YEARLY EXAM -- BECAUSE IT WAS
MY FIRST GYNECOLOGICAL EXAM -- I
WAS NOT PHYSICALLY MENTALLY OR
EMOTIONALLY PREPARED FOR A
GYNECOLOGICAL VISIT -- HE DID
NOT PROVIDE ME A DRAPE COST TO
COVER MYSELF SO ON THE EXAM
TABLE.
ON HE TOLD ME THAT HE WOULD NEED
TO DO A PELVIC EXAM TO CHECK FOR
ABNORMALITIES -- HE DID NOT WEAR
A GLOVE -- AND THE PELVIC EXAM --
TO EXAMINE THE INTERNAL ORGANS
LASTED BETWEEN THREE TO FIVE
MINUTES -- WHERE HE -- HIS HAND
WAS IN AND OUT -- DURING THE
EXAM -- I WHILE HE WAS EXAMINING
ME HE TOLD ME THAT HE THOUGHT I
WAS SO BEAUTIFUL THAT I COULD BE
A MODEL.
THAT MY MOTHER WAS PROBABLY SO
BEAUTIFUL THAT SHE COULD BE A
MODEL AS WELL AND HE I'M.
SUGGESTED THAT I MUST BE A
RUNNER BECAUSE MY VAGINAL
MUSCLES WERE SO TIGHT -- AFTER
THE EXAMINATION ENDED HE ASKED
IF HE COULD TAKE.
OF PHOTOS FOR SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH PURPOSES -- SO WHEN I
READ THE ARTICLE IN THE LA TIMES --
ON JUNE FIRST -- TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WHICH WAS TWENTY THREE
YEARS AFTER MY EXAM -- AND
NEARLY AS A MIDDLE AGED WOMAN I
BEGAN TO DO RESEARCH ON WHAT IS
EXPECTED DURING A GYNECOLOGICAL
VISITS.
I'M I REALIZE THAT I'M MY
EXPERIENCE WITH GEORGE TYNDALL
WAS NOTHING LIKE A NORMAL --
EXAM AS A PATIENT I WAS NOT
PROVIDED WITH PROPER EDUCATION I
WAS NOT GIVEN ENOUGH INFORMATION
TO PROVIDE INFORMED CONSENTS.
I WAS MISLED I WAS CLOSE HEARST --
I WAS VIOLATED [inaudible]
I'M.
AT IN MY RESEARCH -- I FOUND AN
ARTICLE -- BY CALLED YOUR FIRST
GYNECOLOGICAL VISIT ESPECIALLY
FOR TEENS -- AND THIS IS FROM
THE A COG WEBSITE AND IT STATES
USUALLY DO NOT HAVE TO HAVE A
PELVIC EXAM AT YOUR FIRST VISIT
UNLESS YOU'RE HAVING PROBLEMS
SUCH AS LIKE NORMAL BLEEDING OR
PAIN.
HAD I BEEN GIVEN THIS --
INFORMATION BEFORE MY EXAM I
WOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT AN
INTERNAL PUBLIC EXAM WAS NOT
NECESSARY AND IT WAS NO MEDICAL
REASON FOR IT TO BE OFFERED OR
PERFORMED -- ANOTHER PUBLICATION
CALLED THE ANNUAL GYNECOLOGICAL
EXAMS WHAT TO EXPECT -- THIS IS
A PUBLICATION THAT IS ON THE UC
SANTA BARBARA WEBSITE.
IT STATES THE DOCTOR WILL IN
MANUALLY EXAM THE REPRODUCTIVE
ORGANS WEARING LATEX GLOVES THE
DOCTORS WILL INSERT ONE OR TWO
LUBRICATED.
FINGERS INTO THE **** AND PRESS
ON THE LOWER ABDOMEN WITH THE
OTHER HAND IN ORDER TO
PHYSICALLY FEEL THE FEMALE
INTERNAL REPRODUCTIVE ORGANS.
AS WITH THE OTHER COMPONENTS OF
THE PELVIC EXAM THIS PROCEDURE
SHOULD NOT BE SHOULD BE QUICK --
AND CAUSE ONLY MILD PRESSURE OR
DISCOMFORT -- GIVEN TIS
INFORMATION I WOULD HAVE KNOWN
THAT THE DOCTOR WAS VIOLATING MY
RIGHTS -- THAT HIS NECK ITS
FINGERS SHOULD HAVE BEEN GLOVED --
AND I WOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT HIS
MAKE IT FIG BIRDS ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO MOVE IN AND OUT
REPEAEDLY.
NOR SHOULD THE EXAM HAVE
OCCURRED FOR SO LONG OR BEEN SO
PAINFUL.
I'M I ASKED THE MEMBERS TO
CONSIDER A SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT
BY LAW FOR AB -- TEN THIRTY
BECAUSE IT WILL PLACE KNOWLEDGE
INTO THE HANDS OF PATIENTS --
ANOTHER PIECE OF INFORMATION
FROM THE A COG WEBSITE SAYS THAT
THEY RECOMMEND THAT -- PATIENTS
HAVE THEIR FIRST EXAM BETWEEN
THE AGES OF TIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN
I'M THAT IS MUCH YOUNGER THAN
WHAT I EXPERIENCE WHEN I WAS IN.
THE EXAM ROOM -- MY CONCERN THE
IF A SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT IS
NOT REQUIRED BY LAW PREDATORY
DOCTORS WILL NOT BE INCENTIVIZE
TO OFFER THE EDUCATIONAL
PAMPHLET TO THEIR PATIENTS --
MANY MANY OF DOCTOR GEORGE
TYNDALE'S PATIENTS CLAIM THAT HE
DID NOT GIVE THEM A DRIP COUGH.
AND THAT HE DID NOT WEAR A GLOVE --
SO I ASKED THE QUESTION WHY
WOULD HE MAKE SURE THAT HIS
FRONT OFFICE STAFF WAS --
OFFERING THE PATIENTS AN
INFORMATIONAL POUND FAT PAMPHLET.
AND THEN WHAT IS FURTHER
ALARMING IS THAT HE WAS ALLOWED
TO BUY U. S. C. TO QUIETLY
RESIGN WITH A FINANCIAL PAY OUT
AND FREE OF ANY SPOT OR BLEMISH.
TO HIS MEDICAL LICENSE WITH HE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD THIS
DESPITE COUNTLESS COMPLAINTS
MADE BY VARIOUS PATIENTS.
AND CHAPERONES TO VOICE CONCERN
TO THEIR SUPERVISORS WINDOWS
PRACTICES WERE INAPPROPRIATE.
THEIR VOICES WERE NOT ENOUGH AND
AS YOU CAN SEE IT ISN'T ENOUGH
TO HAVE A CHAPERONE IN THE ROOM --
OR TO TRY STE -- THE
ADMINISTRATORS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING WHEN THEY ARE -- POSED
WITH -- OF YOU KNOW I'M.
IN INAPPROPRIATE -- DOCTOR -- I
BELIEVE THAT A SIGNATURE
REQUIREMENT WOULD HAVE ADDED
ANOTHER LAYER OF ACCOUNTABILITY
ON USC'S ADMINISTRATORS TO
PROPERLY INVESTIGATE THESE VALID
COMPLAINTS -- AS IT STANDS TODAY --
THE SEXUAL ASSAULT REPORT THAT I
HAVE MADE WITH THE LAPD IS WELL
OUTSIDE OF THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONSPERMITTED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- SO I HAVE
BEEN EPRIVED OF MY ABILITY --
TO PROPERLY -- PARTICIPATE IN
THE CRIMINAL CHARGES AGAINST
DOCTOR GEORGE HANDLE -- I LIVE
WITH PAIN AND FRUSTRATION THAT
HAD I BEEN INFORMED -- THIS MAY
HAVE PREVENTED ME FROM BEING A
VICTIM.
AND A PREVENTED HUNDREDS OF
OTHER PATIENTS FOR ANOTHER
TWENTY YEARS FROM BEING VICTIMS --
AND THEN JUST THIS MONTH.
ON JUNE TENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE LA TIMES HAS
REPORTED -- THAT ANOTHER
GYNECOLOGIST IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR ALLEGED
MISCONDUCT DURING GYNECOLOGICAL
VISITS [inaudible]
I'M.
MY FAMILY IS HERE WITH ME IN
SUPPORT -- INCLUDING MY THIRTEEN
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER -- SHE IS
FORTUNATE TO HAVE A MOTHER.
I'M INTERESTED AT ALL IN HER
LIFE OU CAN EDUCATE HER.
AND WARN HER AGAINST POSSIBLE
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT OF HANDS OF
PREDATORS -- SHE WILL BE
PREPARED AND EMPOWERED -- WHEN
SHE GOES INTO HER FIRST
GYNECOLOGICAL EXAM AND SHE WILL
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT TO EXPECT?
I'M WHAT ABOUT THE REST WHAT
ABOUT THOSE THIRTEEN A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD WOMEN THAT ARE GOING IN
FOR THEIR FIRST EXAMS.
WHAT ABOUT -- IMMIGRANTS THEY'RE
COMING IN.
OF MY MOTHER IS -- AN IMMIGRANT
FROM MEXICO -- SHE CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY WHEN SHE WAS ABOUT
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD -- SHE WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE -- THROUGH
ANY OTHER MEANS OTHER THAN BEING
PRESENTED WITH THIS FORM -- TO
BE PREPARED YOU CAN.
YOU COULD JUST WRAP UP NOT THAT
BE GREAT OKAY I'M AN THAT'S AND
TING TOGETHER RIGHT I ASKED THAT
WE ENSURE THAT ALL WOMEN.
AND GIRLS ARE -- INFORMED ABOUT
THEIR THESE MEDICAL DECISIONS --
ON WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO COLLEGE
IT WAS IT SHOULD BE LIKE THANK
YOU CHRISTY THANK YOU FOR COMING
IN AND SHARING YOUR STORY.
RAY JUST OF YOU.
WHEN ASKED IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO PLEASE
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE?
JENNIFER SO MOST OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
GREAT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR. THIRTY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CREATE SOME SPACE THE TABLE FOR
TWO WITNESSES OF THE GREAT.
AND BECAUSE SAID THE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT TO GO OVER TIME I'LL
MAKE SURE THAT THAT YOU HAVE
PLENTY OF TIME AFTER HE CALLED.
EQUAL TIME SO.
PLEASE BEGIN OKAY GREAT I'LL
START SO THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR HAILING Q. I'M
AN OBGYN FROM DAVIS AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT AND BRING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE TO LIGHT --
AND WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE TIME
AND WORK THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
PUT INTO IMPROVING AB TEN THIRTY
AS WELL AS THE THOROUGH ANALYSIS
THAT WAS PROVIDED.
SOMEONE LIKE YOU KNOW THE A COG
FULLY SUPPORTS.
EDUCATING OUR PATIENTS --
REGARDING EXAMS AND MANY OTHER
THINGS AND WOULD NEVER CONDONE
THE SHAMEFUL ACTIONS OF DOCTOR
TEN HELL. FOR ANY SEXUAL
PREDATOR FOR THAT MATTER.
THE STATUE THAT THIS BILL AMENDS
ALREADY REQUIRES PHYSICIANS TO
PROVIDE INFORMATIONAL PAMPHLETS
TO PATIENTS REGARDING
GYNECOLOGIC CANCERS.
AND DOES NOT REQUIRE THE PATIENT
TO SIGNED ACKNOWLEDGMENT FOR
RECEIPTS -- WITH THE CURRENT GEE
WHY AND CANCER PAMPHLET
PROVIDERS LIKE KNOWLEDGE RECEIPT
AND OF THE INFORMATION IN THEIR
MEDICAL NOTES -- AND RECORD IT
THAT WAY.
DOCUMENTING THE PROVIDER NOTICE
HOW WE ACKNOWLEDGE ALL CARE
TREATMENT AND ALL INFORMATION
THAT A PATIENT RECEIVES.
DURING ANY APPOINTMENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TODAY WOULD STILL REQUIRE
THE PATIENT TO SIGN AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THEY HAVE
RECEIVED THE PAMPHLET.
THAT THIS TO BE TRACKED IN THE
MEDICAL RECORD AMONGST THE
HUNDREDS. TO THOUSANDS OF
ENTRIES.
THE LEGISLATION SETS A NEW
PRESIDENT ON HOW INFORMATION EGG
IS A KNOWLEDGE IN A PHYSICIAN'S
OFFICE.
THERE AS I STATED THERE'S NO
PRECEDENT FOR THE SIGNATURE
REQUIREMENT AND IT IS NOT ONLY
BURDENSOME FOR PATIENTS AND
PHYSICIANS TO THAT FOR THIS TO
BE TRACKED.
AND VERIFIED PRIOR TO AN
EXAMINATION BUT CAN HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR
PATIENTS.
FINDING AN ATTESTATION IMPLIES
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE PART OF
THE PATIENT.
OR BY ON THE PART OF ANYONE
SIGNING SOMETHING.
IN PLACE IS AN ONUS ON THEM FOR
KNOWLEDGE IN.
SOMETHING THIS CAN CREATE SOME
BARRIERS IF A PATIENT DOES NOT
WANT TO SIGN OR CANNOT
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE BEING
ASKED TO SIGN THEN WE CANNOT
PROVIDE CARE.
A CAUCUS ASKING THE COMMITTEE TO
REMOVE TWO WORDS FIND AND FROM
THIS BILL.
KEEPING THE PAMPHLET REQUIREMENT
IN LINE WITH OTHER REQUIREMENTS.
AND AVOIDING INADVERTENTLY
CONTRIBUTING TO BARRIERS FOR OUR
PATIENTS WHICH ARE ABOUT TO HEAR
FROM.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME IS
DOCTOR JOICEY TASIA I AM A
RESIDENT PHYSICIAN IN OBSTETRICS
AND GYNECOLOGY SERVING ORANGE
COUNTY AND IRVINE.
I'M ALSO A FORMER PATIENT OF
DOCTOR GEORGE TEND ALL.
I AM AS A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
FRESHMAN AT USC A WENT TO THE
STUDENT HEALTH CENTER -- HOPING
FOR GUIDANCE FOR COMMON
GYNECOLOGIC PROBLEM SOME
ABNORMAL BLEEDING -- INSTEAD I
WAS CONFRONTED WITH ONE OF THE
MOST HORRIFYING EXPERIENCES OF
MY LIFE.
AND DOCTOR TEN DAHLE DURING AN
INVASIVE PELVIC EXAM JUST LIKE
WE'VE HEARD TOLD REPEATEDLY TOLD
ME THAT I HAD A BEAUTIFUL FACE.
THAT I SHOULD BE A MODEL.
AND HE GAVE ME EXPLICIT
UNSOLICITED ADVICE -- ABOUT
SEXUAL POSITIONS IN ACTS THAT I
SHOULD TRY -- AS A PHYSICIAN NOW
I LOOK BACK ON THAT EXPERIENCE
AND MORE THAN FIFTEEN YEARS
LATER.
STILL FEEL THE ABSOLUTE SHAME.
AND VULNERABILITY OF IT.
IN FULL FORCE.
THE ONE THING THAT STRUCK ME
MOST HOWEVER.
THINKING ABOUT MY OWN EXPERIENCE
IN THE EXPERIENCE.
OF MANY OF THE WOMEN THAT I
SERVE.
IS HOW DIFFICULT IT WAS TO COME
FORWARD.
I SUPPORT ARMING ARE YOUNG WOMEN
WITH KNOWLEDGE REGARDING THEIR
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
I DO NOT HOWEVER.
SUPPORT PLACING MORE
RESPONSIBILITY ON SURVIVORS
WHICH IS WHAT I THINK THE
SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT OF AB TEN
THIRTY DOES.
WE HAVE TOO MUCH OF WOMEN.
WE DRESSED CONSERVATIVELY.
WE SMILE WERE NICE TO STRANGERS.
WE DON'T LEAVE OUR DRINKS
UNATTENDED WE WALKED DOWN
STREETS ALONE WITH KEYS IN HAND
WE CALL OUR FRIENDS TO MAKE SURE
THEY GET HOME.
MY FEARS THAT THE SIGNATURE
REQUIREMENT OF THIS BILL WILL
MAKE YOUNG WOMEN FEEL THAT BY
SIGNING THIS FORM IT'S NO THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO PREVENT ABUSE
FROM HAPPENING.
IF I WHEN I WAS SEVENTEEN HAD
SIGNED A PIECE OF PAPER.
STATING THAT I KNEW THE NORMAL
COMPONENTS OF THE PUBLIC EXAMINE
IT HAD STILL HAPPEN TO ME.
I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO KEEP FROM
BLAMING MYSELF. FOR NOT STOPPING
IT WHEN IT HAPPENED OR FEELING
AT FAULT FIRST MAYBE SIGNING THE
FORM AND NOT HAVING READ IT.
AND NOW FEELING RELUCTANT TO
REPORT YEARS LATER.
DOCTORS OFFICES SHOULD BE THE
LAST PLACE AND A YOUNG WOMAN
SHOULD FEEL UNSAFE.
I ASK YOU BOTH AS A PATIENT AND
AS A PHYSICIAN TO REMOVE THE
SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT FROM THIS
BILL.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO PLACE THE
RESPONSIBILITY ON SURVIVORS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND YOUR COURAGE.
AND FORTITUDE AND FOR BEING HERE
TODAY TO SHARE YOUR STORY SO WE
SHOULD AGREE MUCH -- ANY OTHER --
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS WE HAVE A PROPOSAL
SUBMITTED ASKING AT THE SEAMS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MORE CARVALLO THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ALSO ASKING
THAT THE SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT
BE REMOVED WITHIN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMEND POSITION.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY.
THE NO OTHER WITNESSES -- AND
OPPOSITION WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS.
MEMBERS COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
THE CENTER LEYVA CENTER PAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR POWERFUL
TESTIMONY AND ONLY GOT HALF OF
IT BUT THANK YOU FOR COMING
FORWARD IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
DO -- I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I TO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE AT THE
SIGNATURE FOR SOME OF THE
REASONS OUTLINED -- I WOULD AND
I DO APOLOGIZE AGAIN FOR BEING
LATE WE WERE IN -- BUDGET.
WHAT WHAT IS THE NEED FOR THE
SIGNATURE?
SO JUST TO BE CLEAR AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS WAS CLEARED AND
WHEN I PERCENT OF THIS IS FOR
FIRST TIME PATIENTS ONLY.
WOMEN THAT ARE GOING TO FIRST
TIME GOT A DOCTOR'S OFFICE AND
THE REASON WHY WE'RE WE'RE
ADDING.
THE SIGNATURE AS WE WANT THE WE
WANT TO PROVIDE AS MUCH
CERTAINTY AS POSSIBLE.
GIVEN THAT YOU CAN'T FORCE
SOMEBODY TO READ SOMETHING EVEN
IF IT PASSED THE FATE A STATE
LAW SOMEBODY CAN RESULT IN
WHETHER NOT WHAT WHETHER THEY
CHOOSE TO OR NOT.
BUT THE GOAL IS BY ADDING THE
REQUIREMENT OF THE SIGNATURE YOU
CREATE A HIGHER LIKELIHOOD THAT
THE LEAST REVIEW AND LOOK AT THE
INFORMATION THAT IS BEING
PROVIDED TO THEM.
IN REVIEWING THAT INFORMATION
YOU'RE NOT WAVING YOUR RIGHT TO
SUE LATER IF YOU ARE -- TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF BUT WHAT WE WANT TO
DO IS CREATE A SAID I MEAN LOOK
AT WAY OUT WE WANT TO CREATE A
SITUATION WE CAN PROVIDE
INFORMATION AND THE STATE SHOULD
BE THE ONE PROVIDING THAT IN OR
REQUIRING THAT THAT INFORMATION
BE PROVIDED.
WE'RE ALL.
BUSY IN OUR LIVES WE GO TO THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE WE GETHANDED A
LOT OF THINGS THINGS THAT WERE
NOT REQUIRED TO SIGN AND THINGS.
BECAUSE WE DON'T THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT WE REALLY PROBABLY
DON'T READ AND DON'T PAY ANY
ATTENTION TO SO WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS CREATE A SITUATION WHERE
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO PUT ANY
ONEROUS ON THAT PATIENT WILL
WERE TRYING TO DO IS.
KNOWLEDGE IS POWER THE MORE
INFORMATION YOU CAN GO INTO A
SITUATION WITH THE BETTER YOU
CAN BE PROTECTED IT'S NOT LIKE
WE BELIEVE THAT.
THE EN EL A DOCTOR IS MORE.
THIS IS UNLIKELY THAT THIS IS
GOING TO HAPPEN BUT IT IT CAN
HAPPEN.
AND SELL BECAUSE IT CAN HAPPEN
THE STATE REALLY HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE SOME
TYPE OF REQUIREMENT IN LAW THAT
THERE BE.
THE GREATEST LIKELIHOOD AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE PATIENTS CAN
REVIEW THE INFORMATION SO THAT
THEY CAN AT LEAST PROTECT
THEMSELVES IF THEY'RE GOING IT
ALONE.
AND THEY DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE
GOING IN WITH THE PREDATOR OR
NOT AND THAT'S WHY.
I AND I WOULD JUST I WOULD I
WOULD I WOULD ADD ONE THING SO I
THINK IN YOUR TESTIMONY YOU SAID
THAT THERE WAS NO PRECEDENT. FOR
REQUIRING A SIGNATURE ON ANY
FORMS THAT ARE GIVEN I WOULD SAY
THAT.
THERE REALLY IS NO PRECEDENT FOR
WHAT WE'VE DISCOVERED WHICH IS
IN A GYNECOLOGIST WHO HAVE
ABUSED. SEVEN HUNDRED WOMEN AND
COUNTING.
AND SO IN MY MIND THE REASON FOR
REQUIRING THE SIGNATURE.
IS NOT TO PUT THE ONUS ON THE
WOMAN WHO'S RECEIVING NAPA TO
PUT THE ONUS ON THE POTENTIALLY
PREDATORY DOCTOR.
WHO'S PASSING OUT THIS FORM
RIGHT SO IF YOU'RE A GOOD DOCTOR
IN THE STATE TELLS YOU TO PASS
OUT A FORM YOU'RE GONNA PASS OUT
THE FORM.
IF YOU'RE SOMEONE WHO'S
MOLESTING SEVEN HUNDRED WOMEN
GUESS WHAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
PASS OUT THE FORM.
SO IN MY MIND IT'S ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT WE ACTUALLY GET THIS
IN FRONT OF THE WOMEN WHO NEED
IT AND I WOULD JUST ALSO
REITERATE.
THAT NOTHING ABOUT THE SIGNATURE
SAYS.
AND I RECEIVED AN EXAMINATION
THAT.
THAT WAS THIS IT SIMPLY SAYS I
ACKNOWLEDGE I WAS GIVEN THIS
INFORMATION BY MY DOCTOR.
WHICH I AGREE WITH ALL THAT AND
THE MORE INFORMATION THE BETTER
I TOTALLY AGREE -- IF YOU DON'T
GROW UP IN A HOME WHERE YOU'RE
GIVEN INFORMATION ARE YOU DON'T
GROW UP WITH A MOTHER WHO TELLS
YOU WHAT THE EXAM IS GOING TO BE
LIKE.
BUT AS SOMEONE WHO WORKED IN THE
LABOR MOVEMENT FOR TWENTY YEARS
BUT PEOPLE SIGN SOMETHING AT
WORK EVEN IF IT IS JUST SAYING
THAT THEY RECEIVED IT.
EXACTLY TO YOUR POINT LATER ON
THEY THINK I DID SOMETHING WRONG
THEY WON'T COME FORWARD BECAUSE
THEY THINK I SIGN AWAY MY RIGHTS.
AND YOU WE CAN TELL PEOPLE THAT
THEY DIDN'T WE CAN TELL PEOPLE
THAT IT'S JUST YOUR CITING THAT
YOU JUST LIKE A TRAFFIC TICKET
WHEN YOU SIGN IT YOU'RE NOT
ADMITTING TO GUILT YOU'RE JUST
SAYING THAT YOU RECEIVED IT.
BROWN ABOUT ALL OF YOU BUT I DID
KNOW THAT FOR YEARS I THOUGHT
THAT WHEN I THAT'S I'VE HAD THAT
MAY TRAFFIC TICKETS BUT IF I DID.
BUT I JUST THINK THAT I WOULD I
READ I LOVE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO BECAUSE I THINK THERE ARE
SO MANY WOMEN THAT HAVE NO IDEA
THAT WHAT THESE DOCTORS ARE
DOING ARE A JUST AND THAT'S
WRONG.
AND AGAINST THE LAW BUT I REALLY
DO HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANCE EARNS
ABOUT THE SIGNATURE I DON'T KNOW
THAT IT HELPS IT ANYMORE -- I
WOULD LOVE TO TELL YOU THAT WHEN
I'M HEADED SEVEN THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE AND I SIGNED IT I READ
ALL OF IT.
I DON'T WE'RE ALL IN IN A HURRY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT IT MAKES.
A WOMAN READ IT ANYMORE -- IF
SHE HAS TO SIGN IT AND IF SHE
DOESN'T.
SO I GUESS WHAT I WOULD JUST ASK
IS IF YOU CAN REALLY LOOK AT
THAT BECAUSE FROM TWENTY YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE PEOPLE SIGNING
DOCUMENTS.
AND THEY THINK THAT THEY HAVE
SIGNED THEIR RIGHTS AWAY AND I
AM WORRIED -- IT WITH THE
EXAMPLE EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID IS
THAT LATER ON A WOMAN WILL FIND
THAT SHE WAS -- ABUSE OR TREATED --
WRONGLY AND SHE'LL THINK WE'LL
THING AND I SIGNED THAT DOCUMENT
AND NOW.
I CAN'T DO ANYTHING SO JUST FROM
LIFE EXPERIENCE IT WORRIES ME.
THAT ARE NOT APPRECIATE THAT
CENTER AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION WE'VE GONE
OVER A COUPLE DIFFERENT IDEAS
BUT WE JUST HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
LAND ANYTHING ELSE THAT WE THINK
IS SUFFICIENT THIS.
WE WE HAVE MARK MARK.
COMMENTS TO COME SO AT CENTER
PAN OF NEXT.
THANK YOU AND SUMMER CALLED OUT
FIRST OF ALL I I I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU -- FOR WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO -- WITH WITH THE
BILL -- BUT I ALSO SHARE THE
CONCERN OF OF THE OPPOSITION.
IT WAS YOU I AND THAT -- ABOUT.
WHAT THE SIGNATURE DOZEN A I
THINK YOU HEARD THE THE --
HOPEFULLY MOVED TO YOU MOVING
TESTIMONY OF AS WELL -- ACTUALLY
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT FIRST
MANY OF THEM.
OUR PEDIATRICIAN.
AND SO WEIRD -- YEAH WE HAVE.
TEENAGERS.
TO BABY ENGAGED IN SEXUAL
ACTIVITY WHO THEN COME TO OUR
OFFICE AND THEN THEREFORE SHOULD
RECEIVE A PELVIC EXAM AND AND
CERTAINLY AS A RESIDENCY PROGRAM
DIRECTOR WILL WE SORRY EDUCATED --
FUTURE SHINS IN TERMS OF HOW --
TO WHAT -- NOT JUST HOW DO WE DO
THE PUBLIC BUT WHAT HOW YOU KNOW
THAT THEY NEED TO HAVE A
CHAPERONE THE NEED TO WALK
THROUGH AND TALK THROUGH EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND WHY WE'RE
DOING IT.
SO THIS IS ALL PART OF WHAT THE
EXPECTATION IS -- IT IN IN IN IN
THE EXAM.
AND RECOGNIZE THAT WE ASK AND
OFTEN DO MANY OF THE FIRST
POLITICS -- FOR FOR EXAMS FOR
FOR FOR MANY YOUNG WOMEN
[inaudible]
AND CERTAINLY A PAMPHLET.
CAN BE HELPFUL -- BUT I I THINK
IT'S REALLY GOING TO BE THE
WALKING THROUGH BUT I AT BUT I
AM CONCERNED ABOUT.
WHAT EXACTLY WHAT?
THE SIGNATURE MEANS RIGHT IS
THIS WAVE I'M DOING THE RIGHT
THING -- THEY'RE TRUSTING I'M
GOING IN THE RIGHT THING IF I'M
NOT I CAN STILL HAND I MEAN.
WE CAN STILL HAVE THE PAMPHLET.
AND YOU CAN HAVE ALL THE
DIFFERENT PARTS IN THERE.
BUT IT'S AND OF COURSE I
PERSONALLY I'VE NEVER HAD A
PUBLIC EXAM -- BUT EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT YELL.
IT IT'S NOT IT'S NOT SOMETHING
YOU JUST KIND OF READ ABOUT GO
OH YEAH THAT'S WHAT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE HAPPENING TO ME OF IT
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING TO ME IF
THE PERSON WHO'S ACTUALLY
PERFORMING EXAM.
IN THE ROOM IS NOT YELL IS
SAYING NO THIS IS FINE AND
THAT'S WHATEVER THAN.
WHAT YOU GUYS DO OR SAY WELL
THAT'S NOT WHAT I READ IN THE
PAMPHLETS BUT SO?
I GUESS THAT -- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THEY HAVE THE
INFORMATION BUT I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS THE THE THE THE THE
EFFECT OF SAYING WELL YOU KNOW
YOU SIGN THIS THING AND WE CAN A
LOT OF PAPER HEARTS TO PEOPLE
AND PEOPLE SIGN A LOT OF THINGS.
AND I'M NOT SURE REALLY MEANS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO READ IT WE
TELL SOME OF THE SITE I MEAN AT
THE WHEN YOU GO TO THE FRONT
DESK AND I WAITING BY KIDS I
GUESS STACK INSIDE HERE SIGN
HERE SIGN HERE SIGN HERE AND LET
ME READ IT OVER.
BUT IT'S THAT THAT MEAN IT
THEY'RE JUST SOME THERE'S
THERE'S SO MANY DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT.
THEY GET HANDED OUT AND AND I AM
AFRAID THAT THERE IS AN
IMPLICATION WHEN YOU SIGN
SOMETHING I MEAN ANYTIME SOMEONE
ASK YOU SIZE OF THE YOU KNOW YOU
GO ON LINE AND THEY SAY WELL
AGREE OR NOT AGREE TO ALL THIS.
DALLEK PAGES AND PAGES OF STUFF
LIKE AGREED BECAUSE I JUST WANT
TO GET TO WHATEVER I WANT TO DO
ON LIKE.
WE'LL DO FEEL LIKE WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT I SIGNED IT SO THEREFORE
WHATEVER'S IN THERE EVEN IF I
DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE READ EVEN I
DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND IT.
NOW I'M IN A HURRY I JUST WANT
TO GET MY EXAM GET GOING -- THEN
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT AND THEN AND
THEN WHAT HAPPENS FOR YOUNGER
YOU KNOW -- YOUNGER WOMEN WHO --
AND MID TEENS THE OF WHAT DOES
THAT REALLY MEAN TO WHEN THEY'RE
SAYING WHAT DO THEY REALLY THINK
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE IN IN.
AN EIGHT AND EIGHT I GUESS MY
CONCERN IS IS WHAT SPEND EXPRESS
THIS IS THAT.
THEY MAY COME AWAY WITH THE
IMPRESSION LIKE WELL I AGREED TO
THIS I EVEN SIGNED SOMETHING
AGAIN I SIGNED A LOT OF THINGS
TO SAY AGREED TO IT I'M SIGNING
SOMETHING FOR THIS PARTICULAR
EXAM IS THAT [inaudible]
MEAN THAT.
IF IT'S NOT OKAY DON'T FEEL
RIGHT ABOUT IT THAT.
I AGREE TO IT ANYWAY IT'S SO SO
I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH THE BILL AND AND AND
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT.
THE IT'S GOOD THAT PEOPLE BE
EDUCATED HAVE INFORMATION.
BUT I AM CONCERNED THAT THAT
THAT SIGNATURE.
PUTS PEOPLE IN THE WRONG FRAME
AND AND SO -- YOU KNOW I I
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT YOU'LL
STRONGLY CONSIDER REMOVING THE
STATE I'M NOT SURE WHAT YOU'RE.
THAT IT'S CHEATING THE AIMED AT
LEAST THAT'S AND STRESS SO FAR
AND COMMITTEE IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE WITH
WITH THAT SIGNATURE.
ED I HAVE A COUPLE OTHER
SENATORS I WANNA MAKE COMMENTS
LUNCH A HOLE THAT JUST ANOTHER
MINUTE.
I'VE CENTER CHIANG AND SENATOR
HILL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FOR BUT I
ALSO DO SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS --
AS MY COLLEAGUES REGARDING THE
SIGNATURE ASPECT -- IMMEDIATELY
WHEN I THOUGHT ABOUT THIS.
IN A WOMAN'S BODY IS DIFFERENT
AND AREAS.
CAVITIES ARE ARE DIFFERENT AND
WHEN YOU.
GO TO AN EXAMINATION UNLESS YOU
HAVE X. RAY VISION YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON INSIDE A
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE.
TO AS A DOCTOR YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE. TO TO EXPLORE AND I DON'T
THINK THAT.
I IN THE PAMPHLET.
IT'S IT'S IT'S IT CAN BE ONE
SIZE FITS ALL JUST LIKE.
BODIES RIGHT AND SO HOW WOULD
THAT WHEN YOU WHEN YOU SIGN
SOMETHING A I ALSO AGREE WITH
WITH DOCTOR PAN THAT -- AS A
YOUNG PERSON THEY MAY THINK --
I'M JUST SIGNING THIS THING BUT
WHAT DOES THAT REALLY MEAN SO IS
THIS HOW THE THE EXAM SUPPOSED
TO GO I MEAN I THINK IT CAUSES A
LOT OF CONFUSION -- ESPECIALLY
AS A WOMAN -- HAVING GONE
THROUGH HEALTH EXAMS IT'S NOT
EVERY EXAM IS THE SAME.
AND THE PROCESS IS NEVER GOING
TO BE THE SAME.
BUT IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION AND ALSO THE
WALK THROUGH THE DOCTOR SHOULD
BE TALKING YOU THROUGH AS TO
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE DOING.
EXACTLY WHY THEY'RE DOING IT I
THINK THAT IN TERMS OF A MORE --
TAILORED -- METHOD OF CARE IS
BETTER THAN JUST A YOU KNOW.
HALF WITH THAT I DON'T THINK
REALLY GETS THE NEEDED PROBLEM
THAT'S THAT'S MY PERCEPTION I AM
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SIGNATURE ASPECT BECAUSE THAT
MADE COURAGE SOME YOUNG WOMEN
WHO HAD EXPERIENCE -- DOCTORS
WHO ARE NOT DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
THEY MAY THINK OKAY WELL I FIND
SOMETHING I DON'T THINK I CAN
COME FORWARD NOW I WISH I HAD
READ.
YOU KNOW WHATEVER THIS.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DO AND SO SO I
DO HAVE CONCERNS AND I'M HOPING
THAT THE AUTHOR CAN.
WORK THROUGH THAT OF WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON A FIND SOME.
SOME OTHER WAY.
SENATOR HEALTH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND UP.
IS IT AYE I LOVE THIS
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY WE HAVE
EVERYONE HAS DIFFERENT OPINIONS
AND AND MINE IS IS DIFFERENT
THAN THE ONES YOU'VE JUST HEARD
I I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THE SIGNATURE.
I THINK THAT -- IT'S JUST SINCE
YOU'VE INDICATED ONLY.
SIGNIFIES THAT YOU RECEIVE THE
PAMPHLET -- AND THERE IS A
PRECEDENT I HAVE LEGISLATION TO
YEARS AGO IF A DOCTOR IS ON
PROBATION FOR SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE OR OTHER THINGS
THEY HAVE TO GIVE.
THAT INFORMATION TO THE PATIENT.
AND THE PATIENT HAS TO SIGNED
RECEIPT OF THAT INFORMATION SO
THAT THEY KNOW THAT THEY HAVE IT.
AND THE OTHER PART THAT I FIND
IF YOU TRUST IN THE POSITION OF
DOCTOR TYNDALL WHO WE KNOW
VIOLATED SO MANY WOMEN.
THAT HE GAVE THIS INFORMATION TO
THEM.
AND HE JUST NOTED IN HIS HE
WOULD NOTED AND PROBABLY NOT DO
IT AND NO ONE WOULD EVER KNOW
AND THEY CERTAINLY WOULD NOT
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF THAT
INFORMATION THAT I THINK.
IS CRUCIAL FOR AN UNDERSTANDING
THE SPECIALLY FOR THAT FIRST
TIME -- SO I'LL BE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND I THINK THE
SIGNATURE IS JUST.
WHAT IT IS?
A KNOWLEDGE MINT OF RECEIPT OF A
PIECE OF PAPER WITH INFORMATION
ON ALL RIGHT -- LET ME AT THE
SHARE MY THOUGHTS -- I PERCENT
PRECIADO THANK THE GOOD
CONVERSATION WITHOUT AROUND THE
AROUND THE TABLE TODAY.
BUT THE SO I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET WITH YOU -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND AND TALKED OF ALL
SIDES OF THE MATTER -- PRIOR TO
THIS HEARING AND FIRST I
APPRECIATE THAT THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED ABOUT THE
PHRASE UNDERSTAND SIGNED THAT
YOU.
RECEIVE AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU'VE THE KNOWLEDGE THAT THAT.
THAT FUNCTION OF UNDERSTANDING
IS GONNA BE INTERPRETED
DIFFERENTLY AND THAT YOU'VE
AGREED AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL
TO LEAD TO DELETE THAT THAT
REQUIREMENT.
AND I THINK THAT WAS HELPFUL.
AND SECONDLY THE CONCERNS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN RAISED BY MY
FRIENDS IN THE MEDICAL FIELD
ABOUT THE BURDEN ON THE DOCTOR
OF OF ACTUALLY.
GETTING THIS PERSONALLY FROM
EACH PATIENT.
THAT YOU'VE ELIMINATED THAT
REQUIREMENT AS WELL TO REQUIRE
THAT THE OFFICE THE FIRST VISIT
REQUIREMENTS NOT HEY AN ANNUAL
REQUIREMENT.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A
CONSTRUCTIVE STEP FORWARD IN
TRYING.
TO GET TO THE PROBLEM THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET TO WITHOUT
PLACING MORE BURDENS ON THE
POSITION THEMSELVES.
THAT IT COULD BE DONE WITHIN THE
OFFICE ENVIRONMENT [inaudible]
AND THIRDLY WHAT.
IS TO BE DEVELOPED BY THE
MEDICAL BOARD.
WHICH IS A PEER SUPPORTED
ENGAGEMENT TO GET THOSE WHO HAVE
THAT.
THE EXPERIENCE I TO TO WRITE
THIS THEN PROVIDED TO ALL THE
PHYSICIANS I THOUGHT AS A VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE STEP FOR THOSE WHO
WORRY ABOUT THE LANGUAGE THAT
MIGHT BE USED FOR THE
DESCRIPTIONS THAT MIGHT BE
OFFERED -- GIVEN THAT DIVERSITY
OF FOLKS -- HAVING THIS
PROCEDURE AT DIFFERENT POINTS IN
THEIR LIFE -- I ALSO THOUGHT
THAT THAT WAS A VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE ENGAGEMENT THAT
WASN'T TRYING TO SAY THIS IS
WHAT YOU MUST DO -- IT'S REALLY
TRYING TO SAY THOSE WHO ARE THE
PROFESSIONALS IN THE FIELD HELP
TOGETHER COLLECTIVELY COME UP
WITH WHAT IS THE BEST WAY TO
DESCRIBE THESE THINGS -- AND I I
A I AM SENSITIVE TO THE ISSUE OF
THE SIGNATURE AND BUT I GUESS
WHAT -- WHAT WAS PERSUASIVE TO
ME IS THAT?
LOOK AT THE STATUS QUO TODAY.
THERE IS NO SIGNATURE THERE IS
NO PAMPHLET.
A WOMEN HAVE -- I HAVE -- FELT
THAT IT WAS ALL THEIR FAULT FOR
YEARS WHERE THEY DIDN'T COME
FORWARD -- BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT
THAT -- IT WAS THEM WHATEVER THE
REASON VERY AND REPAIR IS
REASONS ARE.
I'D THAT THAT'S THAT'S OUR
CIRCUMSTANCES TODAY.
AND IF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH YOUR LEGISLATION TO TRY TO
MAKE IT BETTER. TO TRY TO FIND A
AND AN AVENUE THAT COULD PREVENT
THESE PREDATORS FROM UNDERTAKING
THEIR THEIR WORK. FOR ME THE
SIGNATURE OF RECEIPT SEEM LIKE A
A MODEST STEP FORWARD WITHOUT A
BIG BURDEN ON THE MEDICAL
OFFICES THAT WOULD PERHAPS
PERHAPS BECAUSE WE DON'T REALLY
NOW.
A POTENTIALLY COULD COULD MAKE A
POSITION WHO WAS A PREDATOR
THINK TWICE ABOUT WHAT THEY WERE
GOING TO DO.
AND SO IT IT'S WITH THAT BROADER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WORK AND
THE GOALS THAT YOU BOTH HAVE --
AND THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN THAT MAKE THE BILL FOR ME
AN APPROPRIATE ONE TO MOVE
FORWARD TODAY.
SO THAT'S THAT'S MY THOUGHT ON
THE MATTER ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM UP COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SENATOR DOT.
JUST TO BE CLEAR IT'S RECEIPT
OLE NOT UNDERSTAND ANY OTHER FOR
THANK YOU.
THAT'S CORRECT OUR YET AT CENTER
ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I THINK THIS IS A STEP IN THE IN
THE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION I
THINK THE THE LADY WHO CAME
FORWARD TOUCH MY HEART SO MUCH --
I WISH IT DIDN'T HAPPEN I'VE GOT
TWO DAUGHTERS OF I I CAN'T EVEN
IMAGINE THEM GOING THROUGH THAT.
BUT IF THERE'D BEEN SOMETHING ON
THE TABLE THAT EVEN FOR A SECOND
THEY WOULD LOOK AND MAYBE THINK
AND WALK AWAY OR MAYBE THINK OR
MAYBE SOMETHING THAT WOULD.
INFLUENCE SAID DR IN TO BE
CAREFUL WITH THIS ONE BECAUSE OF
THIS OR THAT.
AND YOU KNOW THAT THE SIGNATURE.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT -- MIGHT BE
A LITTLE SCARY BUT AT THE SAME
TIME IT PUT SOMEBODY ON CHECK IN
ON NOTICE.
THAT YOU'RE ABOUT TO DO
SOMETHING AND I'VE GOT A
SIGNATURE YES I RECEIVED IT
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
BUT IT'S THERE AND I I JUST
CAN'T SEE THAT HOW THIS WOULD
HURT -- SO I'VE GOT TO SUPPORT
IT.
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION I THINK YOU --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BOTH OF YOU -- IT TO
TAKE CARE OF THE THE YOUNG WOMEN
THAT THEY'RE IN SCHOOL AND AND
IT IT'S GOT TO SEND A MESSAGE TO
EVERYONE.
THAT WERE WATCHING.
AND UP.
SO WHY I THANK YOU FOR IT AND
I'M.
THINKING OF OF YOU AND I'M
TAKING MY DAUGHTER SO AGAIN I
SAID I SUPPORTED I THANK YOU.
YEAH.
THAT ARE LEYVA I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT I I JUST I JUST DISAGREE
WITH THESIGNATURE AS I AS I
SAID EARLIER AFTER TWENTY YEARS
OF WORKING IN AN INDUSTRY WHERE
PEOPLE WERE REQUIRED TO SITE
FIND SOMETHING.
THAT JUST MEANT THAT THEY
RECEIVED IT AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS
WRONG AND THOUGHT THAT THEY HAD
SIGNED AWAY THEIR RIGHTS -- I
DON'T THINK THE SIGNATURE HURTS
ANYONE EXCEPT THE PATIENT I'M A
LAYOFF TODAY.
AND I'M HOPING YOU CAN DO
SOMETHING BECAUSE INFORMATION IS
GREAT.
THE PAMPHLET THE INFORMATION I
LOVE ALL OF THAT BECAUSE I
STATED BEFORE A LOT HAS TO WILL
GROW UP IN FAMILIES WHERE THEIR
MOM OR SOMEONE TALKS TO THEM
ABOUT WHAT TO EXPECT.
BUT I JUST FEEL THAT THE
SIGNATURE DOESN'T DO ANYTHING TO
HOLD THE DOCTOR ACCOUNTABLE I AM
WORRIED THAT IT IS GOING TO HARM
THE PATIENT BECAUSE LATER THAT
WOMAN WHO MAY HAVE BEEN.
SERIOUSLY INJURED OR MOLESTED OR
WORSE IS GOING TO THINK THAT SHE
SIGNED HER RIGHTS AWAY BY
SIGNING THAT -- ANYONE WHO'S HAD
A PELVIC EXAM THE GENTLEMAN HERE
BUT FOR US WOMEN.
I'M FIFTY TWO YEARS OLD AND
EVERY YEAR WHEN YOU GO IN YOUR
YOUR LITTLE ANXIOUS AND WHATNOT
SO IF YOU'RE A YOUNG GIRL A NEW
PATIENT.
AND YOU HAVE TO SIGN SOMETHING I
JUST THINK THAT THE PERSON MORE
HARMING IS THE PATIENT SO I HOPE
WE CAN WORK ON THAT.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SOME
CHANGES SO THAT I CAN SUPPORT ON
THE FLOOR THANK YOU.
OKAY WITH THAT I'M GONNA GIVE
THE AUTHORS THE OPPORTUNITY
CLOSE BEFORE WE WE COLOR.
TAKE ABOUT JUST VERY BRIEFLY I
THINK.
INDUSTRY FALLS IN THE CATEGORY
AS THINGS FRANKLY WE SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO WRITE LAWS ABOUT RIGHT
BUT WHEN WE SEE.
WHAT?
IS HAPPENING WE SEE HOW MANY.
WOMEN HAVE BEEN HURT.
I THINK WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
AND I THINK OUR GOAL IS TO
ENSURE THAT.
WOMEN HAVE KNOWLEDGE AND WOMEN
HAVE POWERS THEY ENTER.
IN INTO THE SITUATION.
AND I THINK WHAT WE WANT IS WE
JUST ONE MORE CAN ABILITY AND I
I JUST FEEL LIKE IF WE HAVE THE
THE SIGNATURE IN PLACE IT
PROVIDES A LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY ON BEHALF OF THE
OFFICE.
IF.
IF THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN REYES WELL
AT IT WHAT IS THE OFFICE JUST
SIGNS THAT I HANDED YOU THIS
INFORMATION WELL THEN THEY CAN
JUST SEND YOU THE INFORMATION
AND SAY THAT THEY SIGNED OR THEY
CAN NOT HANDED THE INFORMATION.
AND THEN DECIDED ANYWAYS AND
WHAT ALSO IS INCLUDED ON THAT
PAMPHLET IS INFORMATION ON IF
YOU FEEL LIKE THERE WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS DONE TO YOU
THAT WAS INAPPROPRIATE HERE'S
WHERE.
YOU CAN GO AND GET.
YOU KNOW WHERE YOU CAN GET IN
FOR MORE INFORMATION WERE YOU
CAN FILE A COMPLAINT AND THERE
SOME TYPE OF ABILITY FOR YOU TO
GO SOMEWHERE -- TO TO SEE IF YOU
WERE WRONG OR NOT IF YOU WERE
WRONG TO TO HAVE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY BROUGHT FLORIDA
AND THIS IS A MODEST STEP --
STATUS QUO HASN'T BEEN WORKING I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND
THE OTHER MEMBERS THAT HAVE
SPOKEN UP IN SUPPORT AND IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S WORK THAT WE
AGREE.
HOW CAN CONTINUE TO HAPPEN --
AGAIN IT'S A SENSITIVE SITUATION.
AND I'M A GUY IT'S AWKWARD FOR
ME TO HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THESE
THINGS BECAUSE IT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH ME.
BUT IT DOES HAVE SOMETHING TO DO
WITH MY TO KEEP KIDS THAT ARE
YOU'RE VERY YOUNG DAUGHTERS.
I WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATED
IF I THOUGHT I COULD BE OUT OF
ONE DAY I AM IN A POSITION BUT I
KNEW I WAS IN A POSITION I COULD
HAVE DONE SOMETHING ONE OF THEM
WAS TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF AND I DID
NOTHING.
AND AND I FEEL LIKE THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO PROVIDE A LEVEL
ACCOUNTABILITY TO PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION THAT CAN HELP IN
EVEN IF IT'S JUST ONE PERSON IT
WAS ONE PERSON AND THAT'S BETTER
THAN A ONE SO WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY GREATEST
FEAR.
THAT I JUST WANT TO ADD TO IT AS
I APOLOGIZE I DENY KNOWLEDGE YOU
EARLIER SOME MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS I KNOW YOU'RE
SITTING THERE AND I RECOGNIZE
SOME RECALLED AROUND BUT IN A
SENSE IT WAS LISTED AS CALDERON
BUT I WANTED TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT.
AND THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA ASK FOR A
MOTION JUST A MOMENT BUT I IN
AND AYE AYE AYE ONE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE YOUR WILLINGNESS --
TO WORK TO PUT MAKE SURE THE
PAMPHLET IS AND LANGUAGE IN
WHICH THE PERSON MAY UNDERSTAND
YOU INDICATES BANISHES SOMETHING
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO AND YOU LOOK
AT THE OTHERS I WANT KNOWLEDGE
THAT.
I ALSO ONE OF THE KNOWLEDGE YOU
WILLINGNESS TO APPLY THE THE
LEGISLATION -- TO ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S LICENSE AND
THE APPROPRIATE WAY TO CONDUCT
THESE EXAMS WHICH IS NOT HAVE
FORMAL TECHNICAL AMANDA BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT.
I KNOW YOU INDICATED YOU WILLING
TO TRY TO ADVANCE AS WELL.
SO I SENATOR HILL -- MOVING THE
BILL AND WITH THAT THAT'S THE
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
GLAZER HI GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
ARCHULETA -- TO LET AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
HILL HILL AYE LEYVA [inaudible]
HAN.
WILK.
WILK AYE.
ALL RIGHT SO THAT HAS AN EFFORTS
TO GET APPLE WILL HOLD THE REAL
OPEN TRAPS MEMBERS THE MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THE
PATIENTS OF OUR LAST AUTHOR
WHO'S IN THE AUDIENCE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN.
LIKE TO INVITE HIM UP.
THIS IS A THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
TEN ASSEMBLY BILL [inaudible]
FIFTEEN FORTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN WELCOME SIR. TO OUR
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE -- ANOTHER ROSE ANOTHER
NON CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE THAT
WE'RE HEARING TODAY YES AND ARE
YOU LOOKING TO BEGIN AS SOON AS
YOU'RE READY.
I WILL LET ME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FORTY IT'S A
MEASURE TO SUPPORT THE MUSIC
THERAPY PROFESSION.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
STAKEHOLDERS FOR COMING TO THE
TABLE AND WORKING WITH MY STAFF.
I WORKING WITH MY STAFF -- TO TO
RESOLVE SOME OF THE OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS.
I AB FIFTY FORTY DEFINES A
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE NECESSARY
IN ORDER TO BECOME A BOARD
CERTIFIED MUSIC THERAPIST IN
CALIFORNIA.
MUSIC THERAPISTS ARE HELPFUL TO
A WIDE RANGE OF INDIVIDUALS FROM
HELPING AUTISTIC CHILDREN
DEVELOP THEIR VERBAL AND SOCIAL
SKILLS TO HELPING VETERANS
MANAGE THEIR P..
T. S. D..
HOWEVER INCONSISTENCIES
INCONSISTENCIES IN STATE
REGULATION HAVE CREATED
CONFUSION IN THE LICENSED
PRACTICE OF MUSIC THERAPY.
CERTAINLY PEOPLE WITHOUT
CERTIFICATION EDUCATION CAN USE
THE TITLE OF CERTIFIED MUSIC
THERAPIST.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY WILL MAKE IT
UNLAWFUL FOR ANYONE FROM USING
THE TITLE OF BOARD CERTIFIED
MUSIC THERAPIST UNLESS THEY'RE
REGISTERED BY THE AMERICAN MUSIC
THERAPY ASSOCIATION.
THE BILL WILL NOT REQUIRE A
MUSIC THERAPIST EMPLOYED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO OBTAIN
CERTIFICATION AS A BOARD
CERTIFIED THERAPIST.
I HAVE WITH ME -- STEPHEN BETTS
RETIRED CINEMA COUNTY HEALTH
SERVICE DIRECTOR AND BOARD
CERTIFIED MUSIC THERAPIST TO
SPEAK A OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS LEGISLATION EVER SPECTRAL
ASK HER RIGHT.
WELCOME SIR AND LADY.
YOU MAY BE YET WITNESSES IN
FAVOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHECK LAYS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- IN
ADDITION TO HAVING WORKED AS A
MUSIC THERAPIST.
AND IN HEALTH SERVICES I'M ALSO
THE PROUD DAD OF A DISABLED SON
AND THE FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THE CONSUMER.
THIS PROTECT.
THE CONSUMER FROM OF
MISREPRESENTATIONS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY OCCURRING.
AND HOPES THE CONSUMER TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REDRESS SO IF
I CAN ASK SOMEBODY ARE YOU BOARD
CERTIFIED MUSIC THERAPIST AND
THE ODDS IS PROTECTED UNDER THE
LAW.
AND I CAN GO BACK TO THE BOARD --
CERTIFICATION BOARD AND GET THE
NUMBER OF THAT PER PERSON I CAN
APPEAL I KNOW THE PERSON WHO IS
REPRESENTING THEMSELVES AS A
BOARD CERTIFIED MUSIC THERAPIST.
HAS A CODE OF ETHICS SAY THEY
HAVE SIGNED AND THEY'LL
FOLLOWING SO I AM SAFE I KNOW
I'M SAFE.
FROM THE PERSON OF FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE HEALTH
PROVIDER WHO SEEKING HELP FROM
AN ALLIED HEALTH PROFESSIONAL --
I ALSO HAVE THE SAME.
REDRESS AND I HAVE THE ASSURANCE
THAT THIS PERSON HAS BEEN
ADEQUATE PLEASE -- EDUCATED IS
SKILLED AND KNOWS THE OTHER
HEALTH PROFESSIONS SO THEY CAN
FIT INTO MY ORGANIZATION.
WE ARE AT A POINT NOW WHERE
AFTER THE RATIFICATION OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY AND
SUBSTANCE ADDICTION EQUITY ACT
WE HAVE THE GROWING DEMAND.
FOR SERVICES FROM ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS IN THE AMERICAS.
INSURANCE HEALTH PLANS ARE
SAYING THAT THEY'RE RELUCTANT TO
PAY FOR MORE HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS I THEY DON'T KNOW
THAT THESE PEACE PERSONS ARE
REALLY SKILLED.
SO THE CHANGE IN THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS CODE HERE WOULD
ALLOW ALL THE THREE PARTIES THE
CONSUMERS.
THE HEALTH SERVICE AGENCIES AND
THE BOARD CERTIFIED MUSIC
THERAPIST A COMMON TO THE SAME --
LITERALLY ON TO THE SAME PAGE
AND GO FORWARD -- WITH THE SAME
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS IS A
SKILLED PROFESSION.
FORGET ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THAT WOULD BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SCENE NINE TO CENTER LATEST MOVE
THE BILL WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
FORGET THE SECRETARY WOULD CALL
THE ROLL.
I SAYS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
AYE DODD.
NOT AYE GALGIANI HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN HI CAN I WILK ALL
RIGHT WILL GUIDE.
VERY GOOD THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ANY WITNESSES THANK YOU.
PART NUMBERS ARE GONNA GO BACK
THROUGH THE ROLE ONE MORE TIME
SO PEOPLE CAN ADD ON TO VOTES.
I SEE WERE MISSING ONE MEMBER OF
OUR COMMITTEE HOPEFULLY WE CAN.
TRACK HER DOWN SO WE CAN NOT.
WE CAN COMPLETE OUR BUSINESS
TODAY BUT LET'S START WITH THAT
FOR THOSE WHO ARE STILL HERE
LET'S START WITH FILE ITEM ONE
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWO TWO EIGHT BY SOME WOMAN
AGUIAR-CURRY AT SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTES.
FIVE TWO ZERO SHARE VOTING I'D
[inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN.
CAN I GET WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN ON THAT WHEN I DIP THREE A.
B. FOUR OH SEVEN ST THIAGO WITH
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TWO ONE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING I GALGIANI -- SEES ME LET
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE PAN.
I CAN I THE ACCOUNT.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA.
SEC AT EIGHT ONE ALL RIGHT THAT
BILL IS OUT.
EIGHT TO ONE NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM.
FOR SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY
FIVE BY OR WENT SECRETARY WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE FLOOR FRANKFURT'S.
FIVE TO ZERO CHAIR READING I
CHIANG.
CHING I GALGIANI.
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN.
AND I PUT THAT BILL AND CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT UP -- ITEM NUMBER FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL MISSION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BUT SIX TO ZERO CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VETTING AYE GALGIANI.
LEYVA LIVE AYE PAN PAN AYE.
I WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF AN
ANATOMY AS WELL -- NEXT WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN THIRTY BY SOME A MEMBER
CALDERON.
A SIX IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR DO
THAT THE END OKAY MUST LEARN
ONCE OBJECT TO THAT [inaudible]
OKAY.
ITEM SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL.
TEN THIRTY HIS MISSION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTES FIVE TWO ZERO CHAIR
READING I CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
LEYVA PAN.
BUT ALL THAT VOTE OPEN I'VE
NUMBER EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY THE
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE FOR ABOUT
SEVEN ZERO CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
READING I LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN PAN AYE.
GOOD THAT'S NOT WHAT'S OF THE
ANA.
AT THAT BILL IS OUT.
NINE ZERO NEXT UP BY ITEM NUMBER
TEN ASSEMBLY BILL. TWELVE FORTY
FIFTEEN FORTY SEASON B SOME
MEMBER HOLDEN FOR SECRETARY
CULTURAL.
MUCHAS DE PASSES SENATE FLOOR
CURRENT BOTH.
EIGHT ZERO CHAIRED BY STIRRING
HI GALGIANI.
AND I WILL CALL THE ROLL OPEN ON
THAT FINALLY OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ONE BILL.
ITEM NUMBER SIX ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER.
CENTER WOULD CALL THE ROLL
THANKS HI CHIANG I'D GALGIANI
LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN CAN I ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ROLE OF AN
ALLEN OKAY SO THAT FOR
EVERYBODY'S HERE I THINK THAT
YOU GUYS HAVE IT ALL COVERED.
WE'RE GONNA.
WE'RE GONNA PAUSE FOR JUST A
MOMENT SEE IF WE CAN GET THE
ABSENT MEMBERS TO COME BACK TO
COMPLETE OUR ARE WORKS OF STATUS
ALL RIGHT SO -- WE'RE STILL
MISSING SOME ABSENT MEMBERS SO
I'M GONNA.
PUT THIS COMMITTEE IN RECESS
UNTIL ABOUT STEP FIVE MINUTES --
TO TO WHICH TIME WILL COME BACK
AND SEE WE CLOSE THE ROLE IN THE
REMAINING ITEMS OKAY THANKS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND WE'LL BE BACK
IN A FEW MINUTES
TO ORDER WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLE ONE
LAST TIME FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WILL START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER --
ONE A SPASM THE BILL TO TO A THE
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
BUT IT IS EIGHT ZERO GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE THAT DOES THAT
BILLS OUT -- NINE ZERO NEXT UP
IS IS TEM.
FOR ITEM FOR ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
NINE FIVE BY OR WHEN IT
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL GALGIANI.
GALGIANI I THAT IS WHAT'S OF THE
MOMENT IS THERE.
THE BILL'SOUT.
NINE ZERO NEXT UP FILE ITEM.
FIVE A. B. NINE FOUR NINE BY
MEDINA THE SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL GALGIANI.
GALGIANI I NINE ZERO ARE THAT
BILL IS AT NINE ZERO NEXT UP
WHEN WE DO THE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM SIX AB TEN
EIGHTEEN SECTOR WOULD CALL THE
ROLL GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO NEXT UP ITEM SEVEN A.
B. TEN THIRTY BY CALDER ON
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL CURRENT
THAT'S FIVE TWO ZERO NOT CHIANG
[inaudible]
GALGIANI.
LEYVA PAN HAD BILLS OUT FIVE
ZERO NEXT UP ITEM.
EIGHT A. B. TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL GALGIANI.
AYE GALGIANI AYE.
THE ROADMAP.
NINE BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO AND FINALLY ITEM TEN
WAS THAT A COMPLETE VOTE.
IS THAT RIGHT HERE OKAY.
OUR THAT COMPLETES OUR AGENDA
THANK YOU ALL AND HAVE A NICE
DAY